Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. I got a very
special guest back by popular demand. I
got my friend Menow here tonight. What's
up, brother?
>> Doing good and uh good to be here from
uh Sin City.
>> Oh, I'm in Vegas.
>> Oh, man. What happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas. We're going to share the truth
and hope it gets to the whole world. It
doesn't stay in Vegas this time, baby.
It's going out everywhere. Going blast.
>> And uh, man, Minnow's always bringing
the heat when he comes on. That's why
people are always asking, "Hey, when are
you going to have Minnow on again?"
Well, tonight's your night. So, I hope
you guys are in this late live. We just
started at 1000 p.m. over here in the
East Coast. I guess Minnow's over there
in Vegas, 3 hours behind.
But, dude, this is actually a
continuation from some things that we've
talked about before. Um, I can't even
keep up with all of it because really
all of this goes so tight-knit together
with the political world, the religious
world, how they're joining together in
these last days. and you you've done a
lot of exposees on Trump and the the
agendas that he has, the things that
he's putting into policy and we started
talking about um the the churches and
how religion is getting involved in
politics and this seven mountain
mandate. If you guys have not heard what
that is, you need to go back and check
out some of the later videos. There will
be links in the description, but stick
around for this because he's going to
kind of fill you in on on what this
stuff's all about. And we are we're
inching the end of time, man. This is
prophecy coming true, fulfilling every
single day. It's something new. And life
goes on. People are just like the days
of Noah, you know, eating, drinking,
giving in marriage. They they don't even
see the signs. And that's what Jesus was
saying was he was saying no man knows
the day or the hour but those who are
watching will see the signs just like
the signs of the seasons of the times.
But there was going to be a lot of
people in the church just like the
Pharisees. They were you know the most
church-going people but they couldn't
even see the signs. They couldn't even
recognize that Christ was here right
there among them even doing signs and
wonders and miracles. they still said
that he was doing it with Satan's power.
So, they were so blinded. And that's the
way I see the church today. You know, uh
Jesus said there's he gave a parable of
10 virgins that fell asleep. And they
all woke up, but only five of them had
enough oil in their lamps or Holy Spirit
to actually make it to that wedding. And
uh I just pray that we are in that camp
of the five virgins that are waking up
and that we can wake up others.
It's what you got for us, man.
>> Yeah, absolutely. Well, the last the
last time that we left off, uh we talked
about, of course, the new apostolic
reformation, the N. Uh some of the
players like Lens Wallnau, uh CP Peter
Wagner, uh we're going to hear hear him
again uh in a different context. uh I
mean the same context but uh uh leading
up to something uh that we're having in
in store for you guys um but also Jay uh
some of the key players um and we're
going to unravel more more of those key
players and what they're involved in
because um uh as we know all roads lead
to Rome right so u
>> and that's what we're going to show
again um so last time we and we're going
to show that video again because I think
it's important that lays the foundation.
Speaking of foundation, uh you lay a
foundation once, right? That's what we
discussed last time at the end
>> uh where uh my my friend Chris Rose was
uh did a little little sermonet that we
did at the end
>> uh about uh ongoing apostles or
were you know are there any apostles
today? Yes or no? Right.
>> And uh I think it's a good refresher and
it helps us to jump jump into basically
the book that Jay An wrote and that's
also something that we're going to
unravel a little bit like what uh and
he's contradicting himself u etc etc. So
uh let's dive in uh the first video uh
that was the last video the last video
that we did but let's do that one uh one
more time. This is video 11.
>> This one here right? Yep.
>> All right, let's check it out.
>> You are to bring heaven to earth through
the spirit of God within you. Is
Zechariah 4.
>> What? I'm supposed to be bringing heaven
to earth to barely get out of bed in the
morning. How am I supposed to bring
heaven with me? Let me back this up just
a few seconds. This
>> is amazing. You are to bring heaven to
earth through the spirit of God within
you. It's Zechariah 4:6. It's not by
your might. It's not by your power, but
by my spirit, says the Lord. And
>> yeah, not by might, not by power, but my
spirit says Lord does not mean that I
have to bring heaven to earth.
>> Right?
>> Taken to bring heaven on earth. But the
second thing that he says is that the
church is founded upon apostles and
prophets. Christ Jesus being the
cornerstone.
>> Yeah. No, no, he didn't say founded
upon. It's built on the foundation
of the apostles and prophets. You don't
lay a foundation twice. Yeah. You you
you lay it once and if your foundation
like
goes kaput, then you're you're you're
the whole structure is going to come
collapsing down. Just saying.
>> It's amazing the interpretation of that.
And a lot of people who don't believe in
apostles and prophets today will say,
"Well, the prophecies referring to the
Old Testament, the Bible, and apostles
referring to the New Testament."
When you think about it, think about
Paul's an apostle. He begins Romans 1:1
says, "Paul, a bondervant of Jesus
Christ called
>> Yeah. You You didn't say the word
foundation."
Isn't it weird that he just like omitted
that word? He said founded upon. No, no,
no. The church is built on the
foundation of the apostles and prophets.
See, you see, just let just read the
text in context and you sit there and
go, "Oh, yeah. I get it."
>> To be apostle, he knows what an apostle
is. And he's traveling with a prophet
named Silas at this point. Began with
Barnabas.
>> Now, you're going to note here, it
sounds like he's arguing that the church
needs apostles ongoing.
>> We'll get to that in a second, but I
want you to note that. I mean, he this
sounds like it's an argument for ongoing
apostles and he's going to go somewhere
to try to prove that, which is going to
give you the heebie-jeebies if you think
about it. But, uh, let's let's uh not
get too far ahead of ourselves, shall
we? And then later when Barnabas and
Paul had their parting of the ways, he
picked Solace, another prophet. And then
he goes and says and elaborates this in
Ephesians 4:1 that when Jesus ascended
after he descended because he had to
first descend to take the spoils of
>> Okay, so now he's conflating this now
with Ephesians 4:11. We'll get there in
a minute. But notice he's made the jump
and watch what he does here. And it's
important that uh you know your pastors
know Greek. And I'll explain that in a
minute because it's going to be very
helpful to take a look at the Greek
because he's going to put an emphasis on
a word that actually doesn't appear in
the Greek. Uhhuh. Yeah. I'm just saying.
But watch what he does.
>> Or destroy the principalities and powers
taking their authority.
He ascended and he gave gifts.
>> Mhm.
>> To the body.
>> Yeah.
>> That's you. He gave some to be apostles,
some to be prophets.
>> Now, notice what the word he's
emphasizing there. Some.
>> He gave some to be apostles, some to be
prophets. Now, I'm going to back this
up. I want you to hear his thought in
context. And then we'll take a look at
the Greek on this
>> to the body. That's you. He gave some to
be apostles, some to be prophets, some
to be evangelists, some to be pastors
and teachers to the equipping of the
saints for the work of ministry until we
come to the fullness and this the full
stature of Jesus Christ until we become
a mature man. How many know we're not
there yet? We're not mature. We're not
full yet of the fullness of Christ. And
we haven't come.
>> So notice we're we're not full yet. We
haven't matured to this point yet.
Therefore, his argument ergo is we need
we need apostles ongoing
>> into the kind of unity God wants us.
Until then, we are always going to need
apostles, prophets, evangelists,
pastors, teachers. So,
>> no, no, what he said. Until then, we're
always going to need, let me back this
up. Listen again because this is vital.
>> I mean, no, we're not there yet. We're
not mature. We're not full yet of the
fullness of Christ. And we haven't come
into the kind of unity God wants us.
Until then, we are always going to need
apostles, prophets, evangelists,
pastors, teachers. So, the con,
>> now this is where we're going to do a
little bit of work in the Greek. And
we're going to take a look at Shayon's
brand new, brand spanking, hot off the
press, new book about modernday
apostles. We'll even take a look at what
Bill Johnson has to say about it. But
don't tell Dr. Michael Brown. Anyway,
>> so Ephesians chapter 4. Uh, it would
help if I actually typed in the address
here. Ephesians chapter 4 verse 11 is
the one in question and uh let me pull
this up to you know to be kind of
concurrent and so we're going to look at
the Greek. I'm going to read this from
the Greek kats
a doen and he gave tous tous is the
definite article you know so it's the
and it's plural here it's a plural
accusative and then men here you could
say means on the one hand uh and so when
you give a list of things oftentimes in
Greek men will be the first thing in the
list and then the next parts of the list
will have will have the uh uh the
particle de and that means and so And he
gave kai outas. He adoken gave uh the
apostles men you could say on the one
hand to prophetas and prophets Tuesday
yuan galistas. Uh this is the evangelist
Tuesday uh pouyos shepherds and kai
dasculus uh and uh and the teachers
uh for the uh katarismon
the equipping of the hagon the the
saints uh in into the work of ministry.
Yeah that that's kind of how that works.
So we're going to note here when we just
walk through the Greek words kayato
sedoken he gave tous the men you can say
on the one hand apostles
to and prophets and
evangelists and
shepherds and teachers. It doesn't say
some H. In fact, the ESV does a really
good job of pulling this across almost
word for word. And the ESV, which is
right here in the middle, and he gave
the apostles, the prophets, the
evangelists, the shepherds, and the
teachers.
And so to equip the saints for the work
of ministry, for the building up of the
body of Christ. Now, a little bit of a
note here.
>> Peter is still teaching the church
today. So is Paul.
So is John.
So is Matthew. H how are they doing so?
Through the living active word of God
that they wrote. Uhhuh. They're still
teaching us today.
>> So now Shayon makes a point that oh well
you know that we we in order to equip
the saints we need apostles ongoing. He
he's b this is an argument for this is
this has had to keep going. Now a little
bit of a note here.
>> You talk to people in the N even Shayon
and they'll note that um you know uh
apostles have only recently been
restored.
Wow, dude.
>> He broke that down good.
>> Huh? He brought that down good because
the the Shaon guy, I think that he was
kind of saying
um that God was going to bless some to
be this and to be that. But when you see
it like this,
>> right, when you see it like this, he's
saying, "I gave you apostles. I gave you
prophets. They're in my word. And here
they are. They are equipping the saints
in God's word."
>> Yep.
>> So that's Wow, man. Satan is so subtle,
so cunning, so crafty. And um I I did a
video before about a book called In Awe
of Thy Word, and it's really breaking
down how
uh it it it's a book that's really
proving that the KJV is like the most
perfect translation. I I prefer the KJV,
but I do know that there are certain
verses that other, you know, like this
is the ESV. it did a better translation.
But what it's showing is how many of the
newer translations have been completely
their meanings are completely twisted by
just omitting one word or you know yeah
just like changing a word. So there's
something that said like Israel is a
flourishing vine. All these verses
talking about how Israel is this
blossoming vine but the KJV says it's a
withering vine. So that's completely
changes. And so this is what Satan's
doing. He he is so subtle to be able to
change things like this. And this is
really like a um kind of like a Catholic
mentality like we need to have you have
to have a pope. Nobody can understand
the Bible without uh a leader to tell
you how to interpret it. Right.
>> You're saying something very interesting
and we're getting there.
>> Oh, interesting. You're you're spilling
uh spilling some beans. But we'll we'll
get some somewhere with this exactly
what this is exactly
the point. Now, also what he was saying
is we need to bring heaven to earth.
>> Where in the Bible does that say that do
do we have to bring heaven to earth? No.
Jesus is coming back. He's not
>> he's going to bring Well, yeah, he but
he's going to bring us to heaven. He's
not even bring bring heaven to earth,
>> right? Yeah. Not not right away. Yeah.
You know, I guess people I I already see
the arguments in the comments or
whatever. It'll be um you know, the
Lord's prayer says as in heaven as on
earth or
>> Yeah. But it has nothing to do uh that's
also used as like uh like oh if you
declare and and and proclaim uh like uh
like uh you know like the the the
prosperity preachers do. Yeah.
>> Uh like you know they uh they use that
verse as well like yeah that's where it
says right uh what uh if you if you
declare it in heaven then you declare it
here on earth. That's not how it works.
Um right and and basically you have to
pray because
>> uh somewhere else it says like you know
you're not getting getting something
because you're not asking.
>> Yeah.
>> Like well
>> you have not because you asked not.
>> Yeah. But a lot of people are asking
things but they're asking the wrong
thing.
>> Right. Exactly. They're not asking
according to God's will.
>> Even if they have good intentions and
think so. Um,
not everything that you pray for are you
going to get. And for good reason. God
knows what's best. And sometimes
you end up in a place that you never
wanted to be in, but God sees where
that's going to lead to. Joseph didn't
want to be in the pit, but it got him to
the palace. And it it what Satan meant
for evil, God meant for good to save
many people. and it saved the whole
nation, a whole world basically from a
famine because of being in that
situation.
So God knows best and and that's we
really have to um we have to prove that
you know that we do we really trust God
even in the hard times times when when
when things look like they're going
wrong. We have to put our trust in God
and say God I I know you have a plan
through all this. I know there's a
silver lining.
>> Correct. Correct. So, uh but the
interesting thing is is that Shan is
saying uh that you know apostles
that ongoing apostles are needed, right?
>> That's that's the the message that he's
bringing.
>> But where have those apostles been in
the last 2,000 years?
Good question.
>> There were not any.
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> and
I I cannot name any apostle.
>> Me neither. No.
>> After Paul or after basically John John
passed away, right?
>> Right.
>> I haven't seen any.
>> Yeah. So, that's kind of what the N
means, right? New apostolic reformation,
new apostles.
>> Yeah. Man, it makes me think of a a
verse in the Bible that says like if
they come teaching a new gospel or a new
Jesus.
I think Paul wrote about that.
>> And isn't it interesting that there
hasn't been any apostles, but then uh in
the last days that you have to watch out
for, you know, false apostles.
>> Yeah. Exactly. False apostles. Yeah.
Wow.
>> All of a sudden they're coming on the
scene, right? So it's like, okay.
>> And when they asked Jesus, "What'll be
the sign of your coming?" He said, "Let
no man deceive you." Like that's my
first warning. Let no man deceive you.
Wow.
>> So, in the next video, uh, so, uh, Sean
Sean wrote a book and, um, in that
video, he's going to gonna, uh, I think
it's this video, if you roll the video,
he's gonna, uh, I think going through
through that book. So, that's going to
be interesting.
>> Okay.
Let me kind of prove that to you. So,
modernday apostles by Shayon, operating
in your apostolic office and anointing.
That's the name of the book. So, let's
take a look at well the uh the forward.
And in the forward, we're going to note
that in this particular one, we're uh
listening to who's the fellow who wrote
this part? Oh, this is Bill Johnson.
Okay. So, this is Bill Johnson. Here's
what Bill Johnson wrote in the forward.
We are an hour in an hour where God is
and watch the word
>> restoring
the apostle in a way that reflects his
beauty while avoiding the pitfalls of
prior generations. One of the evidences
of this rising water level for the
miraculous in the church is just a
byproduct of the restoration
of that gift. Hm.
>> So, Shayon on the one hand is arguing
that
we're we always, you know, that we we
need the the apostolic, we need apostles
ongoing for the equipping of the saints.
And yet, Bill Johnson, who wrote the
forward, is saying they've been
restored.
>> They've been restored. in in the um
endorsement portion in the front part of
the book, uh Pastor Jimmy Evans writes,
"Shayon is my dear friend and a true
modern-day apostle."
>> Wow.
>> No, he's not. There is no one operating
in the apostolic anointing that I
respect more than Sheay as a student of
the modernday restoration of apostles
and prophets.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. you a note here. You Jimmy Evans
and Bill Johnson are saying that
you know apostles have been restored yet
Shayon is arguing
that apostles have you know that we need
them ongoing in order to equip the
saints. H that's a little weird. Now
here's another one. This is directly out
of the book itself. Shayon writing. He
says we can now say we are living in the
new apostolic age because God is
restoring the truth of that gift and the
office of apostles is for today
>> restoring.
>> So uh he might claim to be a five-folder
but h how many centuries
how many millennia did the church go
without
>> apostles? Good.
>> I just wonder.
>> Uh then further into the book, page 29,
Shaon writes, "Even though the latter
reign movement has not been universally
recognized in the body of Christ." I
came out of the latter rain movement, by
the way. It's a cult. Uh I thank God for
its leaders. They are pioneers in that
they taught that apostles are for today.
Unfortunately, it sometimes happens that
when God restores a truth, some of his
followers can become extreme in the
application
of that truth.
Shayon then on page 30 writes,
"Similarly, let's see here. Uh, sorry,
through a move of the Holy Spirit also
in the 1940s, I believe that the office
of evangelists was restored." You see,
not only was, you know, did we lose
apostles, apparently we lost
evangelists, too.
>> Wow. Uh so there were no how long were
we without these guys. So there were no
evangelists, there were no apostles,
there were no prophets, you know, and so
watch what he does here. So talking
about the you know how in our times I
mean God is restoring all of this
exciting stuff that somehow got lost,
you know, for a long long long time. So
through a move of the Holy Spirit uh
also then in the 1940s I believe the
office of evangelist was restored
besides Billy Graham and Bill Brightite
during this time period a lot of healing
evangelists came forth uh TLS born
Morris Morris Cerillo really
>> Morris Cerillo
okay so uh yeah yeah this is just nuts
now uh next page uh then he also says
this the Jesus people movement began in
1967 prominently but not exclusively
through Chuck Smith and the Calvary
Chapel Church movement and the office of
the teacher was restored. Apparently we
had no teachers.
>> No teachers. Wow. So we had no apostles.
We had no teachers. We had no
evangelists. We How was there a church?
There was nobody equipped for nothing.
>> And yeah, you
kind of get the idea here. Uh moving to
the next page 32. Also during the same
period, a lot of prophets were coming
forth. People such as Cindy Jacobs
and Chuck Pierce,
[laughter]
>> Chuck Pierce of Goooo Banana Town.
>> Prophets.
>> Yeah. So, because of that, he believes
the 1980s, uh, prophets were restored.
>> Not making that up. That's in Shayon's
book.
>> Uh, same page, just a little farther.
Um, so we read, "So, what period are we
in today?" Hey. Well, Bishop Bill
Hammond wrote a book called The Day of
the Saints, and he believes that God has
restored the apostles, the prophets, the
evangelists, the pastors, and the
teachers to equip the saints for the
work of ministry. So, we're now in the
Day of the Saints. Apparently,
>> oh, you know, we we the whole how I
don't know how long, maybe millennia, we
we had none of those things. So, we we
so thankfully God's restored all the
stuff that we've been missing. Um and
then uh page 39 Shaon writes the
expression of Christianity has shifted
from individual salvation to discipling
nations which includes so social
transformation to bring about this God
has restored the office and the gifts of
the apostle through apostolic networks.
So note he's arguing on the one hand
that we oh the we have to have the
ongoing apostles but then he keeps in
his book he talks about restoration
restoration. Restoration restoration
restoration. By the way what's his
definition of an apostle? His definition
is listed on that same page. An apostle
according to Shayon is a Christlike
ambassador with extraordinary authority
called and sent out by Jesus Christ with
a specific assignment to align the
church to bring heaven's culture to
earth and fulfill the mandate to
disciple nations.
Yeah. So all of that being said, we come
back then to Shayon's video and we note
that his argument seems to be for
ongoing apostles. I'm going. But his
book is all about restoration.
Restoration of apostles. So, let me back
this up just a smidge and see if I I I
just want you to hear what he said again
and then we'll keep going forward.
>> That's you. He gave some to be apostles,
some to be prophets, some to be
evangelists, some to be pastors and
teachers to the equipping of the saints
for the work of ministry. until we come
to the fullness and this the full
stature of Jesus Christ until we become
a mature man. How many know we're not
there yet? We're not mature. We're not
full yet of the fullness of Christ. And
we haven't come into the kind of unity
God wants us. Until then, we are always
going to need apostles, prophets,
evangelists, pastors, teachers. So the
context of if
>> until then we're always yet his book is
all about restoration. So we haven't
always.
>> Wow, good point.
So contradiction contradiction.
>> Yeah. Such a good point.
>> Yeah. So
[laughter]
it's uh it's it amazes me that that they
can just talk out of both sides of their
mouth, right? Because that's what they
do. One one on stage they say one thing,
but then in the book they say another
thing. Um it's always amazing that
people
are not aware or not doing the research
uh that they're basically just teaching
you nonsense.
>> Yeah, this guy is wellstied. This friend
of yours doing this. Um yeah,
>> the fact that he's looking to the Greek,
he's reading the book, he's comparing it
to the the video. Um I'm sure there's a
lot of people that are not doing that.
you know, they're just attending this
presentation. They're not opening their
Bible at all, let alone going to the
Greek and they're listening to what he
said and they say, "Yeah, that that
sounds biblical. I get it." But that's
how Satan speaks. Like, I don't
understand how people don't realize this
that that's exactly what Satan did in
the garden. He's like, "No,
>> did God not say you could eat of every
tree?"
>> Well, yeah, but he said, "Not this one."
Right? So, 99% truth is not truth. Uh,
Satan did the same thing to Jesus when
he was saying, you know, uh, cast
yourself off this temple and you'll not
dash your foot upon a stone and all this
stuff. He's quoting scripture
but in a wrong context or leaving out
parts of it. And that's why deception
works because it's not an outright lie.
People don't fall for outright lies
usually if you know you have any kind of
sense to you. But deception is like that
glass of lemonade with a little bit of
poison in it. You'll drink it right up.
And so they're saying that there's been
no guidance.
Uh nobody's been able to understand the
word of God or how to live to how to be
like a Christian because there hasn't
been any apostles,
teachers, evangelists until the 1980s
now.
And so you can see this false revival
happening because I remember in the
early 90s when me and my parents started
going to a charismatic
non-denominational church, we were
following people like Jesse Duplanis and
Kenneth Copelan and those guys. And
that's when that condundolini spirit was
really coming up in the church. Like you
don't even see it today like you did
then. I don't know what was going on,
but um who was that guy? The the guy
from Canada, they actually called it the
Toronto Canada Spirit or what?
>> Yeah. Um John and Carol Arnold. Uh those
were the guys from Toronto, Toronto
Airport Church, Vineyard Church, and
they were
>> Yeah. Toronto Blessing.
>> The Toronto Blessing. Yeah. that that
was coming into the church and Kenneth
Copelan was literally at those events
and he would be freaking out. the whole
church would be um you know just
possessed literally possessed by the
spirit of Satan by spirits of demons by
this condundolini spirit that if you
don't know what that is it's um it's a
part of new age meditation and yoga and
in eastern eastern religions like that
when you open yourself up by doing the
sun salutation you're doing all these
yoga poses oh If you guys are doing
yoga, please stop. Look into it. It is
not just stretching. It's not it's it's
a spiritual practice. It means to yoke
yourself with Brahman. It's you're do
every pose you do is a worship pose to
the sun. And so when you're doing that
stuff and you start doing uh m what is
it? um mindfulness meditation. You're
emptying your mind and you're
visualizing yourself on a cloud and all
this stuff. That stuff's satanic, too.
We're never told, the word of God never
says to meditate by emptying yourself or
your mind. It means to fill your mind
with the word of God, to think on his
promises and his words. And um it's the
complete opposite. And when you do that,
you'll start to have experiences. You'll
blast out of your body out-of- body
experiences. You'll have uh
communication with quote unquote
ascended masters and dead loved ones and
sometimes even Jesus. But that's not how
you get in touch with Jesus. It was
never said to to do that. And so that
that condundolini twitches and creas
comes as a result of messing around with
that stuff. It's a it's a demonic
possession that's happening.
>> Correct. Correct. And the question is
which Jesus, right?
>> Exactly.
>> So, yeah. So, uh you already mentioned
it. So, now uh to tie the two things
together, he's now going to going to uh
um
show like um that the restoration was
not restoration. Well, yes, but at the
same time it was ongoing and how he is
going to going to merge things. All
roads lead to Rome.
>> Trivia 13.
>> All right. All roads lead to Rome
always. Let's check it out.
And yet they will come out with that
statement. So where did that come from?
We have to go all the way back to the
reformation of 1517
because in that period Martin Luther was
coming against the teachings of
indulgence that if you
>> So apparently it's Martin Luther's fault
>> that we've lost the concept of
>> oh wow
>> apostles.
Yeah, that's kind of what he's arguing.
But watch where this goes.
>> A money to the church to help build
Peter's Cathedral which is St. Peter's
Basilica now. Beautiful building. I've
been to Sue and I took our family to
Rome. I was invited to speak and we took
our kids because we wanted to make a
little vacation out of it and do some
sightseeing.
>> And and so you see that building was
built on indulgence. What's indulgence?
Well, if you pay money to the church
either for yourself or for your family
members, you could have reduced time in
a place called purgatory.
>> Right? Indulgences.
Now, we're gonna we're gonna point this
out that yes, this is what launched in
part the Protestant Reformation. This
idea that Rome was raising money by
frightening people into purchasing
indulgences in order to get out of a
mythical place. It isn't even biblical
called purgatory. And the pope was
complicit in all of this. And there's a
reason why I'm saying that because I
think even Shayon will note that that's
not a biblical doctrine. And so there's
a real funky inconsistency that we're
going to see here in where he goes next.
But I I just wanted to point that out.
So uh let's keep going.
>> We're not even talking about reduced
time in hell. We're talking about
reduced time in a place called
purgatory. And there's no biblical basis
for it. So Martin Luther nailed the n
>> right. no biblical basis for it. Now, in
a second, he's going to take a swipe at
soloscriptura
while at the same time affirming
something very frightening. I'll show
you this.
>> Five thesis on woodenberg's door. And
so, salvation is by grace through faith.
We don't have to pay money to receive
forgiveness, right?
>> It's freely given. And the reformation
was on. Tremendous good came out of the
reformation including translating uh the
Latin Bible into common German and as a
result of that literacy rate rose in
Germany. Germany became one of the most
educated and one of the most wealthy and
to this day the education and wealth
levels off the charts because of the
reformation going back to 1517.
>> But here's the problem. They swung to
the other extreme because you see the
pope was called an apostle.
>> Yeah. Apparently, um,
Luther swung to another extreme by
denying
that the Pope was an apostle.
Whoa.
>> Now, I'd like to point this out. If the
pope were an apostle, and he was an
apostle at this time, then um
wouldn't the whole doctrine of purgatory
and indulgences
>> which came from the pope be legit?
>> You see, Shayon quoted that this is not
taught in the Bible when it came to
indulgences. But the Pope of Luther's
time, he he flat out, you know, like
took full advantage of this doctrine and
affirmed its truthfulness.
>> Wow.
>> And he's supposed to be an apostle.
>> Mhm.
>> He was the successor to Peter. He was
the was called apostolic succession.
>> And he they taught infallibility of the
pope that whatever the pope spoke was
equal to scripture.
And Martin Luther said nons.
>> Yeah. That when the pope speaks
excathedra, you know, from the chair.
Yeah.
>> Solar scriptura, only scripture. And
he's not infallible. And we don't hear
from God. And he's not the apostle. He
is a priest like everyone else. So thus
the priesthood of all believers and we
believe that we're all priests. But he
threw the baby out with a bathwater to
say there's no prophetic. M
>> we have scriptures so we don't need and
and yet what do you do with scriptures
like John 10:27?
My sheep hear my voice. I know them and
they follow me.
>> Ooh ooh ooh. I know the answer to that
question. Jesus said to his disciples,
the one who hears you hears me and the
one who hears me hears the one who sent
me. Saying to the disciples, yeah,
because Jesus didn't write nothing,
right? So how do we hear the voice of
Christ?
>> Through the apostolic writing found in
scripture.
>> Uhhuh. That's how we hear the voice of
Jesus. So notice on the one hand, Shayon
is saying, "Oh, m and Martin Luther went
way too far, man. He's denying that
Peter's an apostle and stuff and solos
scriptorer and stuff." And uh and yet he
quoted he said that indulgences and in
purgatory were not biblical.
That's a biblical argument. And so, you
know, he's really in a conundrum here
because there's no logical consistency
to his theology except that he wants to
argue that we we we really do have a we
have an apostle in the church. He's
called the pope.
[laughter]
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. This this is
>> Wow.
>> He went there, right? So, basically, if
if the pope is an apostle, then
shouldn't you listen to the apostle?
>> Yeah. Um,
I don't know how I missed that. He said
that though, did he? That's what the guy
said. He said that he believes that the
pope was an apostle because I heard him
say like um he's a priest and we're all
priests.
>> Yeah. But he was a successor of Peter,
right? That's what what what he says.
So
I mean if that's the case then uh and he
denies some of the teachings then he's
denying what he's saying that you know
that
>> if he's if the pope is an apostle then
he should listen to the apostle. That's
the hypo the hypocritical
>> right thing basically. So he's again
speaking out both sides of his mouth.
>> Oh dear.
>> So interesting. So all the roads lead to
Rome again. Right. So that's how how uh
how people are uh brainwashed basically
to accept to to um oh yeah Luther went
too far
>> so
that's too far
>> then that's too far so no you have to go
back
or at least uh
you have to accept Rome.
>> Wow. That's
>> Yeah.
>> Wow, dude.
Yeah, I I I didn't get to the point I
was making about the um the Toronto
spirit and stuff was, you know, he was
saying that there was none none of these
apostles or evangelists or anything
until the 80s and we saw that false fire
come down. We saw the the false spirit,
Holy Spirit, but it was a false
counterfeit Holy Spirit. And um
we we seem to be seeing more of that
false
spirit today, more of that counterfeit
Holy Spirit. It seems like the church
just cannot figure out, they can't get a
grip on that there can be a false
revival.
I mean, I keep seeing articles right now
of like, oh, like, you know, all these
people, there's a revival in this city
or this town or whatever. in the news
even.
>> Yeah. And you nobody says like maybe we
should uh really see what they're
teaching. Maybe we should scrutinize it
with the Bible, compare it to what
scripture says, and make sure this is a
real one. Maybe we should test those
spirits. Maybe we should see what's
actually going on there. Instead, they
just say, "Nope. They're saying they're
saying the name of Jesus." Their hands
are lifted up. Their eyes are closed.
They're emotional. That's the Holy
Spirit right there. That's all it takes.
>> That's all feelings.
>> Yeah. And And so a lot of people think,
you know, if the guy is if the pastor is
talking about Jesus or pointing people
to Jesus, then he has to 100% be true.
H how do they how do they get that? Do
they not realize that the Mormons
literally go to a church called the
Church of Jesus, Christ of Latter-day
Saints? Like, it's in their title, but
they wouldn't think twice to say that
they're a cult. They understand that
Mormonism is a cult, but they teach
Jesus. Um, newagers believe in Jesus.
They're trying to reach Christ's
consciousness. They think Christ is like
he was the one that reached the level
that we're all trying to get to. So like
you were saying, which Jesus? You can't
just say as long as we all believe in
Jesus, we're we're in a good place. The
Bible says that the devils believe and
tremble and we know they're not going to
be saved. We know that they're not going
to make it. Um, like I said, the the
Newagers, the Mormons, many other cults
out there.
Um, I'm trying to think of some of the
ones that were What were the cults that
the Kool-Aid drinkers and all that
stuff?
>> Oh, yeah. Uh, um, Jones. Uh,
>> yeah, Jim Jones and some of the other
ones. They all were reading right out of
the Bible
and and believing that Revelation is
very real and that we were living in the
the time of the end and all that stuff.
And yet it was a cult. It was not a true
Jesus. And there's a lot of other, you
know, false preachers that teach Jesus.
They read out of the Bible, but they're
these mega churches that are just all
about money and they're getting busted
all the time. Like, who is this guy that
recently got busted? busted. He was He
was literally called Apostle.
>> Uh I can't remember what it
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know the name. Yeah. I I know
what you're talking about. Yeah.
>> Right.
>> Yeah. Oh, absolutely.
>> Apostle whoever. And he had this huge
mansion and cars and and he was uh money
laundering and stuff and yet he said the
name of Jesus all day long, right?
read scripture.
>> Yeah. It's it's unbelievable. And and
the problem is is when when it also gets
politicized, right? So when Yes.
>> Uh when the blurring of church and state
basically is is coming into play. Uh and
and and and
um that's what you see now happening in
the news. Uh it's all about, you know,
uh it's it's about making America a
Christian nation and making the world a
Christian world. U but that's not what
the Bible is telling us that we have to
make everything Christian
>> right
>> um
>> it actually says there will be a falling
away first and then the end shall come
>> correct correct uh and what you see a
lot of Christians and I think uh there
was a research uh that has been done
that half of people that call themselves
Christians uh and if it's and it might
be even the Protestants uh that half of
the Protestants are saying that uh that
they believe that the world is is
getting a you know a better place and
and
>> um so it's frightening that yeah
>> that so many people think that that so
many Christians are thinking that that
uh the world is you know the world's
getting saved
>> and the pope recently just said that
that you know I think it was uh really
recent the new pope he said that
everybody goes to heaven This is
basically the same thing like if
everybody gets saved, everybody goes to
heaven. So it's the same message.
>> Wow. Yeah. The last pope before he died
said all religions lead to God. They're
just different languages to God. You
know, if you you're Buddhist, you're
Muslim, you're Jewish, we all worship
the same God. It's just different
different styles basically.
>> Different form.
>> Yeah. Different form. Uh and uh and so
uh but you see you see what you see with
the N uh is that it's also very
militant. Last video we saw uh Rick
Joiner for the last video, last video
that we did was like Rick Joiner used
military terms and also Dutch Sheets and
I think the next video is also again uh
Peter Wagner and and Dutch Sheets. Um
because it's important for people to see
this video again uh this video 17. And
the reason why is that this is not just
a movement. It is uh very militarist
militaristic
um and uh it's not only the church, it's
the seven mountains of mandate, right?
So it's it's um
>> um it's not this video. I think
>> you said 17.
>> This one we just number 17.
>> Yeah, this is
>> Let me check here. One sec. Oh, no. No,
sorry. Uh oh, wait. No, number one.
>> Number one.
>> Oh, wait. No, no, no. Okay, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. Before we do that,
>> uh, before we do that, yeah, number 17,
uh, must be first. Okay, so I'm ahead of
myself. Sorry.
>> So, in the he he would So, this is the
last video with with the Chris Rosenber
explaining chon in video 17, this video,
you kind of see that. So, so you see a
lot of flavors in Christianity, right?
So you see new apostolic reformation, uh
you see the Pentecostals, you see the
the the charismatics, you see the um
those those churches that are um like
the Bill Hibballs churches uh but also
the seekerdriven churches like arc
churches
>> um and prosperity churches. It's all
different a different flavor of the same
thing,
>> right? And I've been showing people uh
over and over again that it comes all
from the same source. It's just a
different flavor. And they're all lumped
in as an apostle or a prophet in this
movement. Like Kenneth Copeland calls
himself a prophet in the office of the
Lord that he was blowing cover away.
Right. Right.
>> Uh and he's also an apostle in in that
movement.
>> Now same thing with with Bill Johnson
from Bethl Church and this guy Jay. But
there's another group uh or organization
is called arc churches and he's going to
say who who is going to be apostles and
we're going to dive into that because
the uh the secret driven
um churches basically is based on the
model of pet see Peter Wagner and also
uh together with Billy Graham
>> and Bill Hibles those were the ones that
pushed the uh um the whole uh church
growth,
>> no the church growth movement and uh
knocking knocking on somebody's door.
Hey, what do you want to see in church?
Oh, you want a roller coaster? Okay,
well, let's do a roller coaster in
church, right? That kind of you want
coffee? No problem. Where can I get the
Starbucks in in in in a church? That's
all fine.
>> Oh,
you know that kind of stuff. So that's
the the the the the seekerdriven, seeker
sensitive church basically. Um and now
you're going to hear uh Jon say who else
is an apostle. So you can roll this
video
>> 2:20. It's not talking about the Old
Testament. New Testament is talking
about gifts God's given to the church
that we will still need
until really until Jesus Christ comes.
It's amazing how in the evangelical
church I was privileged to in April to
be invited.
>> So notice we always need these until
Jesus comes back. But his book talks
about them being lost and restored
>> to a round table and it was uh all the
megaurch pastors around 20 of them in
Dallas.
>> Oh you got to hear this. You got to hear
who was there.
>> Texas Gateway Church with Robert Morris
was hosting it. Church of the Highland,
a 50,000 member church was there.
>> Chris Hodgeges and Robert Morris are
part of the N.
>> Uhhuh. That's really what's going on.
Listen to what he says.
>> Chris Hodgees. And the list goes on. I
don't want to just name draw, but
they're all churches of 20, 30, 50,000.
Huge. And I'm thinking to myself, what
the heck am I doing here? I'm not even
pastoring, you know, and so yeah, I'm
with them. But they know that I lead an
apostolic macro. And the reason why they
invited me was this is that, and this is
the paradigm shift that's going on in
the body of Christ. stunned me,
encouraged me. They always describe
themselves as a pastor, Ephesians 4:11
pastor. So they call them pastor Robert
or pastor Chris or pastor Larry
Stockdale still. So they were all called
pastors, but they would say we have a
strong gift of leadership. So that was
in the past.
But in the past several years, they've
come to the realization, I am not a
pastor. I am an apostle.
Yeah. Chris Hodes, an apostle. Robert
Morris
an apostle.
>> Wow, dude.
>> So, they stop
>> they stopped calling themselves pastor
and call themselves apostles.
>> Correct. Correct. Um and and mega
churches, right? So 30,000 50,000 is
what he said. Uh and and also like with
those satellite churches, right? They
have like 15 churches uh like uh Greg
Crucial who uh created the the what
Bible app was that um
>> one of those Bible app
on the phone. One of those Bible apps um
is what he created. Now it's so all
these and Robert Morris actually
recently was convicted because he uh uh
and and he is guilty u because of uh
sexual uh misconduct when he 20 years
ago 20 30 years ago whatever. So and
that was the the rain maker within the
N. If you need money you needed to go to
him. Uh he would he would make money
rain for the churches. So, uh, so he was
very, very influential, but now he's
convicted, right? So, but he was an
apostle, right?
>> Wow. And, and we just had this other
apostle guy that was doing illegal
stuff. And then
>> we got people like Perry Stone, same
thing. There was some adulterous
situation going on. Like,
>> wow, there's so many of these people was
not possible. Yeah. Um there were
there's so many of them that that have
been falling uh recently um of those big
shots. Uh but but uh so Chris Hodes is
one of the founders of called Arc
Churches ARC and they're in a lot of
towns. There are thousand of them in the
well in the United States and some of
them are international but a thousand of
them and there is they want to have like
2,000 is their their aim. Uh that's what
they're going for. Uh but here I'll
share my screen for a second. So this is
Arc Churches.
Do you see my screen?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So what they have here, as I said,
fast forward to today, Arc Churches has
se has seen more than 1,000 churches
planted since starting in 2000.
Uh and uh and continues its vision to
see a thriving church in every
community, reaching people with the
message of Jesus. Well, which Jesus is
the question. Uh but they already have
more than 1,000 and their aim is is way
more uh now than that was in the
beginning. So so and now let's see who
is on on who is the founders. Right. So
this is the next slide here. You see
Chris Hodes
>> Church of the Highlands Arc founder the
that's in in um Alabama I believe that
he's has a church. But here you you see
Rich and Michella Bizette also arc
founders arc founders here. Greg and
Debbie Serat. We come back to Greg Serat
in a second. Uh Dino Ritzo he also had
an affair or had something uh that was
also like like an issue a sex sexual
issue but he's uh he's a founder. He's
executive director. He's just back on
the board.
>> He's just leading the churches. Right.
>> It's all fine. Right.
>> M
>> uh and then you go down and uh these are
all uh leaders in the movement basically
in the arc churches movement. Uh and
they do also ch uh like uh um
what is it uh the movies like uh they're
going to uh look at uh Superman and then
uh find Christ. Those kind of things at
the movies it's called.
>> Wow. show a movie and try to find
biblical parallels in there. And
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. All these guys are are
main people in the movement uh in in
that um and when we were in in
Minnesota, we we went to this church
here, Substance Church, and we went to
River Valley Church.
>> Uh so we were in that movement, so we
know all about it.
>> Yeah.
>> Um but yeah, uh
so it's Yeah. uh a lot of people here.
Those are the the heads the the the big
people in in in in this in the in the so
they are the the decision makers
basically.
So very interesting. Uh but back to Gre
Serat so Greg Surat uh so there's an a
movement called empowered 21 and I want
to want you to see this. Here's the
global leaders and I'll go back up here
that you can see that global council
right the global council empower 21
and then you go to do
>> you know what 21 means
>> uh no
>> okay it just made me think of agenda 21
if you ever heard that term in the new
world order
>> because I wasn't sure what 21 meant in
agenda 21 either so what is up with this
Yeah, that's a good question. Yeah, I
don't know. Um
maybe that they started in 2021 or so uh
towards the goal of 20 33 which I'm
coming to
>> but uh these are leaders across the
globe. This guy here Adoa is an apostle
in the movement. This guy is an apostle
in the movement. Uh Cheron is an apostle
in the movement. Heidi Baker is an
apostle in the movement. People know
Heidi Baker. Uh this guy is from the the
uh superintendent of the or was uh from
I think it was the church of God.
Uh then you have um Jurgen Buler who is
the uh he is like a big organization the
the an embassy uh of Israel. It's the
connection with Israel. Uh then you have
u what is it? Andy Bert is from uh from
U
man Descent. It's a massive uh
revival thing that they they put the
like stadiums stadiums full of young
people.
>> Here you have like Christine Kane. She's
from Hillsong.
Uh Cesar Castellanos is from the uh from
a like a cell group church. Uh like um
the G12 is coming from there. So Jesus
had 12 disciples. So you need to have uh
the government of 12, right? So you have
one leader
>> and they need to have 12 leaders for
they raise up 12 leaders and those 12
leaders also are they need to if you
want to be in the tw G12 group you need
to start your own 12 12 a group of 12 at
at some point. So basically another way
of of uh you know um
>> multi-level marketing.
>> Yeah, multi-level marketing. Yeah,
absolutely.
>> Uh then you have Doc Clay who is now the
superintendent of the the Assemblies of
God. Um so that's another big
denomination. We went through that in
another episode. So it's good to know
the history.
>> Russell Effins from Planet Shakers.
Maybe uh some people know the the band
Planet Shakers from Australia. He's an
apostle. Uh Jensen Franklin, he's close
to Trump. Uh and an adi one of on
advisory board, right? Um then you have
Mark Green um from the Hobby Lobby.
>> He's one of the the owners of uh Hobby
Lobby or the CEO.
Um then you have um Timothy Hill. uh he
is from the church of god. The other one
is then from uh the four square church.
It's another u big denomination.
Uh then you have uh Cindy Jacobs uh I
think uh Chris Rose the video that we
saw mentioned Cindy Jacobs as one of the
prophets in the movement. Uh Bill
Johnson also apostle in the movement
from Bethl uh in Reading California. So
they're all on the are on the the global
board right? No.
>> Um here the guy is called Cash Luna.
>> Cash Luna.
>> Interesting, right?
>> Um then you have uh let's see here Terry
Parkman also part so he is also part of
um Arc Churches and uh he is under Rob
Katling uh that is uh on the board here
uh of Ark Churches. Rob Katling is this
guy here and he's in his church. So, um,
and this this guy is from Charisma
magazine.
>> So, he's also in that whole movement.
Uh, and there you see Greg Serat, right?
This is the guy that we talked about.
Greg Serat is right here. This is Greg
Serat from [snorts] the arc churches.
So he's also in the movement like um
>> now these people you're showing on
screen this is the the whatever 21
>> empower 21 and that's a global uh
movement and we're going to see their
mission and vision in a second.
>> Okay.
>> Uh which is very important.
>> Uh and here is Billy Wilson. He is the
the the now the president uh of the Oral
Roberts University. And who is Oral
Roberts? We talked about it in a pre
previous episode. He was the f one of
the founders of the prosperity gospel
right
>> together with Kenneth Hagen.
So uh he is leading Oral Roberts
University now.
So very interesting. Now what is it
indeed what their vision is now? This is
their vision and is this biblical?
>> I don't think so. but uh that every
person on earth
>> would have an authentic encounter with
Jesus Christ through the power and
presence of the Holy Spirit by Pentecost
2033.
>> Okay.
>> Whoa. Uh chapter and verse.
>> Yeah. Do you see that anywhere in the
Bible?
>> No. So the fact that Okay. Pentecost
2033. I'm not sure where that's at in
the Bible. When is every person every
person good and wicked and
>> gonna have a authentic encounter with
Jesus Christ?
>> Very interesting.
>> So everybody goes to uh everybody
becomes a believer if that's what they
say by 233, right?
>> So I guess there's no such thing as like
>> isn't that what the pope just said?
>> Isn't that what what what what the these
N people believe? This is an N
organization. So, I guess there's no
such thing as like a mark of the beast
that dams you. You know that there's
some that are sealed and some that are
marked and once you make that decision,
your sa your fate is sealed. Um, none of
that because every person by 2033 is
going to be Christian. Wow.
>> Well, that's not what my Bible says, but
um
>> Yeah. No, I I missed that one.
>> Wrong translation, I guess. [laughter]
Yeah, you're reading the King James,
man. That's what's wrong.
>> You gotta get that like passion version
or something.
>> Oh yeah, probably. Then their vision,
their mission here is to we will help
shape the shape is is also shape the
future that is n language new apostolic
reformation language of the global
spirit empowered movement throughout the
world by focusing on crucial issues
facing the movement and connecting
generations for intergenerational
blessing and impartation. Importation is
also again the kundalini.
>> Yeah, I was going to say importation.
deportation and then they fall over and
and that kind of stuff.
>> And this is the kicker.
This is the [snorts] new apostolic
reformation.
The seven mountain mandate.
>> This is the seven mount mandate you're
going to read.
>> Yeah. every segment of society including
so empowering
the future generation in every segment
of society including church, family,
government, business and this is eight
but you know uh it is part of the seven
mountain mandate basically.
So
so this is this is very interesting and
and it goes deep and far and
farreaching. If you look at this map
they're everywhere.
It's everywhere. There's global reach,
right?
>> I think we need to explain
>> cabinets. See that? Regional cabinets.
>> Wow. Dude,
>> this is a kind of governmental
church thing.
>> I think we need to explain for people
that maybe maybe they're not getting it.
Seven Mountain Mandate. What's that? I
saw that said, you know, um church and
education, all that stuff. Why is this
wrong?
>> Yeah. So, so what they uh So, bring
heaven to earth, right? and and how they
do that is through all the seven spheres
or seven uh pillars or mountains uh of
influence. So basically instead of uh
you and I talk to somebody else and and
and and share the gospel and that they
accept the gospel, no you need to
transform nations. So you need to
Christianize a nation and that's how
they become Christian.
>> Wow. So we have we we have been taught
wrong according to these people. No,
it's about bringing the nation under
God's authority and then therefore
it will be, you know, and that's what
you see make America Christian again,
right? That's what they what they push
for, make the world Christian again. Uh,
so that's
>> and it's very like that that makes me
think of the u Spanish inquisition, you
know, it's like we're that word make
make America great, make America pray
again, make America religious again, all
these things I've heard straight from
Trump's mouth, that is a forceful term.
You if I'm going to make you go to
church, that's not by your choice.
That's forcing. And so it automatically
makes me think of Revelation and the
mark of the beast when it's saying that
he will cause all to worship the beast.
And we know that a beast is a kingdom.
That kingdom is Rome. And there's going
to be uniting of Rome and America
together because the second beast, which
is America, will cause all to worship
the first beast. And so, yeah, if you're
making America religious again, that's a
forced form of worship, which is never
of God. God's way of worship is free
will. It's love. It's not forced.
And so, when the you got these people
that are saying, you know, we're going
to take over government. We're going to
take over education and entertainment
and media and arts and all this stuff.
That is very papal Romeesque
all the way.
>> Yeah. [clears throat]
And also very aggressive, right? And
>> Yeah.
>> And what you're saying is is correct is
Romeesque. And and that's what what you
know what Rome has been trying to do
from from the get-go, right? Is is make
America Catholic or make the world uh
basically
uh uh fall everything falling under
their sphere. And that's basically what
you see happening.
>> And they say Christian, but it is not
Christian at all. And they do it also
here with the global evangelistic
alliance. And you see another big
committee part of the empire empire 21
label. You see the same thing, right?
Global impact.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is all uh under the the same
umbrella. Um and here you see the
leaders. These are all big in in here.
this guy is doing um uh
I think it's like um um
America shall be saved, Australia shall
be saved, Europe shall be saved
organizations. So they have stadiums
full as well. So it's wow
>> there's so many of these people. Nick
Hall is another guy uh who's who did the
the the mall the thing the big thing in
the mall at the mall in Washington DC in
2016 together 2016 right where the pope
also had a shirt uh uh like you know
with that he was with with Nikol and the
pope
>> and the symbol had the oraoris as the
letter O. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yep. Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> And these are all all a lot of
youngsters. Some oldies, but a lot of
youngsters, too. Uh Todd White here,
>> man.
>> This is a Dutch guy, Mateain.
Um from my home country. So, a lot of
youngsters. Uh Daniel Kenda is one up
upand cominging guy who denies the that
the New Apostolic Reformation exists
just like Dr. Michael Brown that Chris
Rose made a joke about it in earlier in
one of the first videos. Don't tell Dr.
Brown,
>> right?
>> But he's an apostle in the movement as
well. So, but here you see uh another
committee, right? So, they had it's
massive. And here global prayer uh
alliance.
>> Wow.
>> Met the whole senior team. This is Oh,
oh, interesting. when I was in the
Netherlands, she was one of the the the
pastors uh in the church that I went to.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> And she's an apostle now with her
husband uh in the Netherlands.
>> How does one become an apostle, by the
way?
>> Yeah. You have to um be chosen just like
Freemasonry.
>> Freemasons [clears throat] to be one,
ask one, ask one to be one, right?
>> Yeah. And uh and then also you have to
pay you have to pay your duty. So you
have to pay to be an apostle and if
you're if you want want if you are a
couple you get discount. That's how it
works.
>> Look how prophetic this is. The pope
holding this with the American flag. You
got Rome and America together. Rome and
America together with a Oraorus which is
a serpent or the dragon. I mean it's
like insane dude. That is a orus
completely. Wow.
>> [snorts]
>> So, and then here's uh the the the the
young the the the E21 next generation.
So, the youngsters. And here's Terry
Parkman again.
>> He is from the River River Valley
Church. So, he's a NextG catalyst and
lead campus pastor and some young guys
and girls that are uh on the board.
And here, global ambassador ambassador
for the chosen.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> So, yeah, it's all everything is
connected. Everything is connected. So,
then
>> yeah,
>> in case you guys don't know, we don't
endorse The Chosen. We actually expose
the chosen
>> as a
>> a Mormon, a blending of Mormonism,
Catholicism, evangelicalism, and Dallas
Jenkins, the creator of the show, said
90% of the show isn't even based on the
Bible. All kinds of, you know, making
Jesus not care about the law and
there's all kinds of things in there,
man. It's uh well, who's the guy that
plays Jesus? I forgot.
>> Yeah, Jonathan.
>> Jonathan Roomie is a spiritist
necromancer. Um 33 degree Freemason or
Knights Templar actually. This is all
this is not conspiracy theory. It's
straight from his own mouth. He said
>> and also Knights of Columbus too.
>> Knights of Columbus. He he took
>> and he was also going to be kned as
Vatican. uh uh knight or something like
that.
>> I did not know that. Wow. I've seen
plenty of pictures of him with the pope.
Um he posted on his own Instagram
a picture of a dead pope in a glass
coffin and he said, "Uh me and him have
had many talks. He talks to the dead."
He he went to Lonnie Frisbee's grave,
his tombstone, and he said, "This might
be a little too much information, but
instead of sitting on it, I actually
laid on it so I could feel closer to
him." And I asked him, "Lonnie, uh, if
you want me to play you in this movie,
uh, I can't remember the name of them,
but Jesus Revolution, if you want me to
play you, give me a sign." And then he
said the the doors behind him on the
cathedral bust open and the organ rang
out and it was, you know, nobody can
play the organ. It's like this relic
back there. And uh he just looked up and
was like, "Okay, thank you." So he he
communicates with the dead. He's a a
practicing spiritist, necromancer,
Freemason, Knights Templar.
This is the guy who plays Jesus, by the
way, and is telling you to join him in
prayer on the Hallow app as he does a
lotus pose.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, dude.
>> So,
>> don't watch the show.
>> Yeah.
>> No, don't watch the show. So, here you
see the empower 21 women's alliance. So,
there's also a they're trying to sway
women into the church into this this
movement. And this is lady is Christine
Kane again. She's she's [clears throat]
from Hillsong.
Very interesting. So uh back to that uh
uh I'll show you here the map again. Now
look at this map. Okay. And now let's
let's roll
um video one because I think that's very
important now that that we uh hear from
>> this video.
>> Um no no video one.
>> Video one.
>> We come back to that that one next.
>> I don't think that I got I downloaded
one. Peter Wagner.
>> Yep. Peter Wagner. [clears throat]
>> Let me see if I can get this one to
play.
>> Dominion has to do with control.
Dominion has to do with rulership.
Dominion has to do with authority and
subduing.
This is the basics of Peter Wagner and
I'm speaking to you here from Colorado
Springs from the Wagner Leadership
Institute where in our institute we
teach very strongly on the seven
mountains and we teach for social
transformation.
My point is [laughter]
that we're in the second apostolic age
and and the government of the church
must be in place with apostles and
prophets
which brings us to the dominion mandate.
[laughter]
Now first of all I want to point out
these two words dominion and mandate.
The word mandate, you've got to
understand, mandate means an
authoritative order or command. It
doesn't mean a good idea. It doesn't
mean a suggestion. It means an
authoritative order.
>> Dominion has to do with control.
Dominion has to do with rulership.
Dominion has to do with authority and
subduing and it relates to society.
Dominion means being the head and not
the tail. Domin dominion means ruling as
kings. It says in Revelation 1:6 that he
has made us kings and priests. And check
the rest of that verse. It says, "For
dominion Jesus delegated establishing
his kingdom to us." What do I mean? To
you and to me.
>> We are the ones who are the who are
supposed to bring this about. See, Jesus
traeded his disciples to take charge
after he left. Go and put the first map
up on the screen if you would.
These are just circles. The blue circles
represent apostolic networks. We have
them all over the nation. Now, I'm just
deal with America. They're all over the
world, but we have them all over
America. The black dots represent
individuals.
There is an awesome apostolic grid.
There is an apostolic prophetic grid.
There's an apostolic prophetic
intercession declaration
grid over America. We are positioned now
to do anything he wants to do. And
they're out there. Believe me, they're
everywhere. There are apostles in the
military. There are apostles in
government. There are prophets in
government. There are apostles and
prophets in the media.
>> They are there in entertainment. They
are there in education. YOU HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT GOD IS ABOUT TO UNLEASH ON THIS
NATION.
>> WHOA, that sounds familiar.
>> Well, that sounds very familiar. Why do
we hear that?
>> That sounds just like Erica Kirk's
speech and and some of the other
speeches that were happening at Charlie
Kirk's memorial service where I saw some
bald guy saying like, "You've just
unleashed the dragon."
>> The dragon being Satan, of course.
>> Uh, wow, dude.
>> Yeah, that just sounded creepy. that
everything in that clip was like,
>> "Yeah,
>> we're It sounded very like uh Islamic,
you know, like we will
>> Yeah. jihad. Yeah. I call it Christian
jihadism." Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow, dude.
>> Well, and it is militant, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, talking about militant
uh if you if you share my screen, what
what was militant in the back in the day
was
>> the Knights Templars, right? and the
Catholic Church and
>> the orders and the night the knighting
of the of the Templars and the crusaders
and
>> and if we go to today here you see
people are still knighted right uh yeah
Brian May I guess
>> wait I mean what is this context is this
like uh something British or something
or
>> the British is kned right this guy is
knighted by the by the
>> by the king Um uh because the king is a
knight as well. Um
>> and then and then we go to the church
battle in California. What do they do?
>> They do the same thing. They knight
people.
>> Are you kidding me? You should zoom in
on that.
>> Here honoring
being kned by an apostle and a prophet,
the fathers of this house, as they say.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> They're not even hiding it.
>> No. And here again.
>> Whoa.
What?
>> Yeah.
>> And these are students that come there
for one, two or three years from all
over the world and they take over
churches. They become pastors in
churches.
>> And
>> unfortunately, my my cousin went there
for three years and is now one of the
pastors in the church in the Netherlands
>> and spreading false gospel like a virus
through the church. And I I believe that
a lot of these people are sincere, but
they're sincerely wrong. That's what's
so
>> scary about deception is that
when you point this stuff out, people
say, "No, I know that guy. He loves
Jesus." You know? Yeah. Because he's
deceived. Like,
>> yeah,
>> these are people who genuinely want a
relationship with Christ, want a
relationship with God, but they've
fallen into the false teachings. And
that's what the that's what Revelation
talks about being drunk on the wine of
Babylon. Babylon is confusion and it was
also a godless nation. And the wine
represents the Holy Spirit. The they're
drunk on the wine. This is fermented
wine that makes you drunk. The Bible
talks about be not drunk with wine
because it makes kings forget the law
and all this stuff. All of this is
symbolic of saying that
many nations, many kings and everyone of
the earth are going to be drunk on false
um doctrine.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. It's crazy. And here you see uh uh
here Bethl beis Templar nighting
ceremony. Seven mountain men is templar
too.
>> Yeah.
>> So
interesting, right? Interesting. And
then uh this guy here, Paul Lewis Cole,
he is uh part of the C3 movement that's
uh from Australia. Um and uh the the guy
we'll get there in a moment, but uh but
he has uh the Christian Men's Network,
MSN of CM, CMN, I mean. Uh and what they
do is very interesting. He's high up in
the New Apostolic Reformation as an
apostle. uh and he has also apostles on
the board but uh just a few people that
he's hanging out with and what he is
doing. So here you see Lance Wall now
remember he was the guy that uh that
that uh invading Babylon wrote with Bill
Bill uh with Bill Johnson. He was he he
coined the term seven mountain mandate.
>> Okay.
>> Uh so uh we we dealt with him in in the
last video uh in the last video that we
did together.
So he's very close with lens now, one of
the apostles in higher ups in the
movement, right? Very close. He falls
together, you know, with he's on his on
on par with with Chon the use that we
just saw, right? So
>> yeah,
>> then the next one is hang out with Mr.
Creepy Kenneth Copelan.
>> Oh wow,
>> these people are all together, man. All
in the same bed.
>> Yep, they're all the same. Joel O
>> bed with the harlot.
>> Joel Ostein.
>> Yeah, Joel Ostein. They're all And this
is the Ikeel. This the the the
international coalition of apostolic
leaders. That is this is the the highest
uh um I showed that also in one of the
videos that we did. UAL uh leaders. Um
if you look it up that is basically
where uh that's the the
uh that's the one organization that CP
Wagner was the big apostle of
>> and that is now taken over by John Kelly
as you see here in and and I mean all
the apostles are together right and they
have all the flags here hanging out.
>> Wow.
Um, and then here you see him with uh
Phil I said C3 churches, Chris Pringle.
He's the pastor of the the C3 churches
and they're all over the world just like
Hillsong.
>> They're lesser known, but they're also
all across the globe. So, this movement
is so massive.
So massive, you you would think there's
so so much flavor, right? You have arc
churches we we just talked about.
>> Empower 21 is in the global movement.
Then you have the C3 Hillsong all these
different
>> organizations with all kind of thousands
and thousands of churches. Jon had
25,000 churches that he's leading.
Right? So there's so many churches that
are misled by this doctrine.
>> And then you have here, what do you see
in their hands? I'll enlarge it. Oh,
they have knights. But they have
>> swords.
>> Swords in their hands. Militant.
>> Ready to go to war.
>> Very militant.
>> Yeah.
Uh and here more some more pictures here
with swords in their hands.
>> They get a paper and a sword.
>> See what man when Peter pulled out his
sword Jesus said you live by the sword,
you die by the sword. And we are told
that the word of God is the sword of the
spirit. That's how we fight. We fight
spiritual warfare on our knees, praying
to God, uh, quoting scripture, claiming
promises. That's how we fight. Not with
physical swords.
>> Is it TD Jake?
>> Yep.
>> He is also accused of uh homosexual uh
things and with with Diddy.
>> Diddy. Yep.
>> Yeah. And then you see here uh where the
swords and look at the face, right?
>> Yeah.
>> It's a new sound of manhood. Men who
become warriors. What was the video that
we just saw with with it was like they
they were ready to go to war,
>> right?
>> And here you see also swords in in
Uganda all over the world.
>> Wow.
>> Here Uganda.
>> Wow. Oh,
>> uh here again the short
um
>> you know that's the saddest part is this
is the majority like Jesus said
>> narrow is the way to life
>> and few there will be that find it.
Broad is the way to death and
destruction. And you know, back to
Revelation, it talks about how the whole
world basically is going to be drunk on
this wine of Babylon. This is the
majority of the churches. I mean,
Catholicism
is the world's largest quote unquote
Christian denomination. Catholicism,
which is literally
Babylonian paganism veiled in
Christianity, it's the biggest
denomination. And then
>> under that are all these uh you know
charismatic
non-denominational churches like this.
>> Correct. Yeah. And and see here uh in
Peru
>> that looks creepy.
>> And who is there
>> here? President of Peru honoring all
these people.
>> Are they wearing robes and stuff?
>> Uh I don't see it but no there suits.
>> Oh wow. Yeah suits. But but they're all
standing there with swords in their
hand.
>> All warriors, right? And so and and uh
here another one.
>> Wow.
>> All with swords in their hands. Lakewood
Church. What is that? Joel.
>> Joe. Yep.
>> So he's doing it everywhere. So it's all
over the place. Here's um uh Governor
Mike Huckabe.
>> Wow.
>> Very close with him.
And here is uh another picture here with
Emperor again.
Um
and this is uh Texas.
I mean, and here another one
all going to war, you know.
>> Wow, dude.
>> Lakewood Church again.
>> Lakewood, man.
>> So, uh and then this one here. Oh,
[snorts] we tal just talked about Tim
Lehei about no uh the the here's the
link. We talked about Jonathan Roomie,
right? And about Dallas [clears throat]
Jenkins.
>> Now Dallas Jenkins is the son of Jerry
Jenkins. Jerry Jenkins together with
Paul with Paul with Tim Laay wrote
um Left Behind series.
>> Oh yeah. Wow. So there's everything is
so connected
>> and we're not done with this guy yet,
>> Tim Laay. We're not done with him yet.
We're coming back to him in a moment
because this guy is is also crucial in
politics.
And uh here we see uh Jensen Franklin
again very close with with Trump, right?
So also very close with Luis Cole.
Here you see him again
building champions. He says here he has
put L's wall now again.
>> Uh here again with swords in their hands
and um what else did I have here again?
Swords everywhere.
>> Wow.
>> Lakewood church.
It's uh it's militant here. Kenneth
Copeland can hear and hear Kenneth
Copeland and what does he say? A good
day with great friends. So very blessed.
>> Kenneth Copeland Ministries.
>> Good friends.
>> Yeah. All good friends. Buddy buddy and
TBN of course.
>> Yeah. Their their logo is uh is like
some British seal or something.
>> Yeah,
it's a seal. I know. But I didn't know
it was British. Yeah, it's it's it's
crazy. And then so back to Tim Tim
Lehei. Let's see here. Tim Lehei. So Tim
Tim Lehei, he is the first president and
uh of
um
Okay, one one second. Let's let's go
let's let's go back to
um so yeah, the CMP. We're getting to
the CMP, the Council for National
Policy. But first, we talked about uh
about the grit uh of um of uh uh it's
kind of like the now we have the
Christian the church, right? The the
Christians. Now we're going into
politics. Now, we talked about Charlie
Kirk, right?
>> Uh a little bit. Uh let's go uh to video
uh number number
22. 22.
>> Yeah,
>> this one.
>> All right.
>> Y
>> try walking around Brown, Yale,
Princeton, Stanford, UCLA with that hat.
But I'll tell you, finally, we have a
president that understands the seven
mountains of cultural influence.
Finally, we have a president that
understands the significance of
standing. Yes, I'm going to
>> He's talking about Trump.
>> He's Yeah, that was in 2020. He talked
He's talking about Trump. Finally, we
have a president that understands the
seven.
It doesn't matter how you how you coin
the term. Seven mountains of mandates,
seven spheres of influence. It doesn't
matter. It's all the same thing,
>> right?
>> Mountains of cultural.
>> He even said mountain. Seven mountains
of cultural influence.
>> Yep.
>> Understands the seven mountains of
cultural influence.
>> Wow, dude. Yeah. If uh anyone in here is
confused about the whole Charlie Kirk
thing, we got some videos on that.
There's three and I could have kept
going, but I was sick of talking about
it. And really those three videos, if
you if you're not convinced after
watching those, then nothing's going to
convince you. Um, he's part of it, man.
He He You don't get to share the stage
and the screen with Donald Trump, the
president of the United States, who's a
puppet. You don't get to share screen
time and the stage with him and the
mainstream controlled propaganda sewage
pipe unless you are a part of the club.
And he's throwing up hand sign Masonic
hand signs with Candace Owens and other
people. And um yeah, of course, he said
a lot of things that you agree with.
That's how Satan works. you know, he
creates these role models, these idols
that we look up to because he plays both
sides. It's the Hegelian dialectic. He
has to. And so Charlie Kirk was that
person for many people on the right, the
conservative right. You know, that Satan
has uh his idols for the left and he's
got his idols for the right. Charlie
Kirk said all the things that we believe
in that there's two genders that you
know marriage should be up up and rising
again that um
you know that people should get back to
closer to God all these things that we
agree with but
it's crazy how we fall for this stuff
you know they create the chaos
>> so that we actually praise normaly like
it's something special. All he was doing
was saying facts. There's two genders.
Yeah, this guy is awesome.
>> What? That's just like normal.
>> But at the same event, he's praising
he's praising uh the the Mormon church
and there must be more Mormon churches
around around the globe or something in
that nature.
>> So, I'm like uh what?
He he talked about keeping Sabbath,
which was really just putting his phone
away and spending time with his family.
All the while on Sunday, he's in the
pews of Calvary Chapel and at mass
>> or or or mass. Yeah, to say or mass.
>> So, you know, there's all these people
are excited that the Charlie Kirk
effect, people are going back to church
now because of Charlie. Well, which
churches are they going to? the churches
of Babylon, the Sunday churches, the uh
literally Roman Catholicism. That's what
the article said. Um churches, Sunday
church and um mass have skyrocketed
since the incident with Charlie Kirk and
they call it the Charlie Kirk effect.
>> Even Bible the the the selling of the
Bible the the Bible selling of Bibles
have been uh increased.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I hope they're actually
reading them and not just buying them
because read the fourth commandment. I
mean, wow. You know, a lot of people, a
lot of Sabbathke keepers got sucked into
what he said because he promoted the
Sabbath, but in the same breath, I've
watched, you know, you don't have to
send me any clips. I seen when he said
it, he's like there's a clip of him and
his wife on stage and he said, um, you
know, we'll do it today on Sunday cuz
we're here with you right now, but uh,
you know, I I keep the Sabbath. So, he's
saying it doesn't matter. It's Sunday.
I'll do it today. But he said, you know,
normally I keep the Sabbath. And he's
like, you know, I'll debate you on it
and I'll win. Haha. And jokes it around.
He goes, but that's not really what's
important. He said, "What's important is
that as Christians, we've really done
ourselves a disservice by not keeping
one of the seven." Like, everybody got
so hung up that he said the word Sabbath
and he said it was on Friday sunset to
Saturday sunset and he puts his phone
away and all this stuff, but in the same
breath, he's saying it doesn't even
really matter what day it is. What
really matters is that we keep one of
the seven. And he's married to a Jesuit.
Well, a a Catholic baptized Catholic who
graduated Jesuit college and at his
funeral was saying, "Oh, Charlie's here.
I can sense his spirit or whatever. And
go to church this Sunday and the Sunday
after that."
>> You know, it's like the two great errors
uh the
immortality of the soul and Sunday
sacredness joining hands right there
along with church and state. I mean,
it's insane.
>> And this is this is important that this
is the fantastic segue because we're
going to go from church to state right
now and seeing how church and state is
going to blend in.
>> Uh so I don't know if anybody knows and
if you can share my um uh share my
screen again.
>> Okay.
>> If anybody knows the the Council for
National Policy, a lot of people don't
know that this exists. Now, everybody
has heard of the CFR, the Council for F
for Foreign Relations. Everybody knows
about the Build-A-Bear group. That is
the left side of of of of it. The right
the the the Christian Nationalist side,
the the right think is the Council for
National Policy. You would say, "Oh,
yeah, the Heritage Foundation." Well,
the Harris Foundation is part of the
Council for National Policy because the
the guy that's the head right now, he is
part of the CNP, the Council for
National Policy. So, that is the think
tank. This the think tank of of the
Conservative side. They decide who is
going to be president.
>> Ronald Reagan here is chosen by the CNP.
Bush was chosen by the CNP. Trump was
chosen by the CMP. All of these people
were chosen by the CMP on the right
side. They all have to speak and come in
front of the the the the CMP. And uh and
this is very important. Uh and here you
see uh the the the Council for National
Policy uh the it's the Republican Party,
Conservative and Republican Party
initiatives. And it's it was launched in
1981 during the Reagan administration by
Tim Lehei.
>> Oh, what?
>> Exactly. Left behind
>> and the Christian right. Oh, there's not
not not such a thing as the Christian
right. Yes, there is. [clears throat]
And there's nothing like Christian
national. It's just normal. No, it is
not.
>> Wow.
>> It's not. So the CMP is the right wing
and it's uh it has all these members
here. Some of you some of them you might
know uh and see the conservative version
of the Council for Foreign Relations. I
didn't make it up.
>> Mhm.
>> Tim Leah and then uh some others that
have been um the founding members. Okay.
The founding members I don't know all of
them. Some maybe some people will know
him, but uh here
uh shipping magnet Peter Grace, Edin
Fner of the Heritage Foundation.
>> Wow.
>> Oh,
Pat Robertson of CBN Christian
Broadcasting Network. Oh, Jerry Fwell.
Who was Jerry Fwell? Oh, he was uh a
pastor. Uh but he was al he was also uh
the the Liberty University or something
like that. I believe it's Liberty
>> or or was it another at least one of the
the the universities.
So here you have here or Southern
Baptist uh yeah I think it was Trent
Trot is he
I don't know. [snorts] Anyway, uh uh
other names that you see here are uh
Steve Bannon,
Kellyanne Conway was a member of the
CNP.
Interesting because she she literally
lives in the Trump Tower, right? And
she's always with Trump.
>> Then you have Blackwater founder Eric uh
Prince
and also Betsy Devos.
Trump administration secretary, a former
[clears throat]
>> secretary uh of education.
>> This is the church of state all the way.
>> Yeah. Virginia Thomas.
Wife of Supreme Court Justice Clarence
Thomas.
>> Huh.
So I think he's Catholic.
>> Very interesting. Right. And then you
have
uh let's see, it's not over yet because
now you have here
uh oh membership list of 2020 leaked a
year later including I don't know this
person
Michael Ferris
lawyer. Uh interesting. Uh the the most
interesting guy here is Charlie Kirk,
>> huh?
>> Wow.
>> Membership of the CNP, Council for
National Policy.
>> Wow.
>> And he got money from the Council of
National Policy to start up turn the
Turning Point USA.
Tony Perkins,
Matthew Staver, I don't know him.
Um so and then also like uh James Dobson
from the focus on I think he's f yeah
focus on the family.
Um
I mean and this is very interesting. CMP
has membership links to the committee of
the free world
whose many other members included among
others some members of the unification
church of the United States
>> and I'll get to that in a second. We're
going to see a video in a moment. But uh
this I mean this goes here uh in 1999 I
just said it right. Speech was done by
George W. Bush. Oh,
>> here you see Dick Cheney, Mitt Romney,
US President Donald Trump.
It's uh very interesting.
>> So, you got Mormons, you got Catholics,
>> because Mitt Romney was a Mormon.
>> Wait,
>> correct.
>> Yeah, is Yeah. Yeah, he's a Mormon.
>> Yeah. And there was another uh there was
another guy um uh that I found
interesting
and I was talking to you about it
earlier
um
left behind
and who was that
>> I did see um this that on the Catholic
Herald it says Trump's cabinet picks
makes it one of the most practicing
Catholic yet. He he has the most
Catholics on his cabinet of anything.
President-elect Donald Trump has
>> chosen to appoint Catholics to several
key cabinet and senior advisory roles.
It's led some to claim that as a result,
this could prove to be the most Catholic
cabinet the administration in the
history of US politics. Wow.
>> Here, this guy, do you know him?
Uh,
>> former pastor, seven dads with
discharges.
>> H, zoom in a little bit. Matthew.
>> Yeah,
>> I don't recognize.
>> Anyway, interesting. Tim Laay. Um, and
then this guy, this guy is is
from the Mormons
here, church of le saints.
So, it's it's very interesting. Uh uh
and then Richard Devos
uh Mway
>> Mway. Wow.
>> So yeah. So
yeah, very interesting. Very
interesting. So now um uh let's go to
because this it's very important. I I I
mentioned uh a little bit about the
mooneyies, right? the the the
unification church of the United States.
But I think this is a great segue into
uh the Mooney's cult because they're
from South Korea,
>> but they have have a massive influence
in the United States in in in the
politics. They
>> uh I mean they he was um key he gave
money to Tim Leah to set up the CNP.
So, let's see if we can um Yeah, if we
can uh do uh video 21.
>> 21.
>> This is 21, right?
>> Yeah. I
>> Okay.
>> Kind of want to address one comment
before we move on. There's a comment
here. It says, uh,
>> "Mr. Kirk was a loud voice on the
Sabbath, bringing it to the forefront."
Let me read. uh bring it to the
forefront so that now many are looking
at the Sabbath whether or not it's true.
We who are SDA or 7th Day Adventists
have not been speaking about Sabbath.
Um I disagree with that. I see, you
know, there's tons of Adventist
literature that speaks loudly and
proudly about the Sabbath being the
seventh day, not Sunday. um billboards
that say Sunday is the mark of the beast
and the Sabbath is the seventh day. I
mean, I think Adventists are doing a
great job at being very specific about
the day so much that people actually are
kind of turned off like, "Oh, you guys
are worshiping a day and all this
stuff." Um, the thing that I see that's
the only thing I see that Charlie Kirk
did at all was bring up the importance
of keeping a day, which is going to be
perfect for the Sunday law because
Christians have forgotten the importance
of keeping the Sabbath. And so, you
know, even Sundayeping Christians, they
go to church and then sometimes they go
to work or they watch the football game
or they go out to eat. they're not
really keeping the Sabbath because the
Sabbath commandment says don't work and
don't work others and it is a day to
keep holy. Um, so even if they are, you
know, keeping Sunday, they're not really
keeping the day holy. And so the only
thing I see that Charlie Kirk did was
bring up the importance of keeping a
day. He even said one of the seven. And
so that's going to be perfect when the
Sunday law comes around. People are
going to say, "Look, we need to we need
to close down shops. We need to not be
shopping. We need to not be going to
restaurants. We need to not be going to
work because we need to keep a day and
Sunday is the perfect day to pick
because the government's shut down and
all that stuff." And that's not that's
not bringing attention to the true
Sabbath, but bringing um really setting
people up to accept the the false system
of worship that's soon to come, the mark
of the beast, the enforced system of
worship that's soon to come with Sunday
law. So, I you know, I know a lot of
people are getting hung up on the fact
that he was clear about what the Sabbath
was and all this, but I I've heard him I
I can show you the videos where he says,
you know, that's really not what's
important. What's important is that we
keep one of those seven. And so, I I
really think all he did was make get
Christians fired up about keeping a day,
which automatically is going to be
Sunday in their mind because that's the
day that they're familiar with. And uh
he made it very
kind of vague like it can you know we're
keeping Sunday today because we're with
you but normally I keep the seventh day
or whatever. It was just very loose.
Uh okay. So this is the Mooneyies,
right?
>> Yeah. This Yeah. This will explain Tim
Lehee's uh influence and also the
Mooneyies. Uh this is very very uh
interesting to to
um uh basically explaining kind of
where Sunyong Moon is coming in into
play and and what happens and who which
players have been funded by the
Mooneyies by the cult from South Korea.
>> Wow. Okay. For Moon claimed to be the
Messiah. Now, Sunyong Moon, the the the
uh and I've done a study on him, and I
give you the teaching on that,
claims
to be the Messiah on planet Earth. And
we're going to go over all that
information again. It's been a long time
since I did that study. And you're not
going to believe how many people are
yolked up with this guy,
>> this gigantic cult leader. You're not
going to believe how many bibleelving
supposed born-again Christians are
yolked up with this devil. Wow.
>> Okay. Tim Leah, the author of the Left
Behind series, okay, said this to
Sunyong Moon 20 years before Moon
claimed to be the Messiah. Before
Sunyong Moon gave Jerry Fwell $3.5
million
>> for his Regent University
>> or Liberty, I'm sorry. Liberty.
>> Well, Liberty, just liberty.
>> And we're going to get to that, too.
before Jerry Fwell.
>> Regions.
>> No, no, Liberty.
>> Liberty.
>> But Regent, Regent is from is from uh
the other guy uh that also is from the
CMP. Uh the the guy that also started
CBN uh Pat Robertson. He's from Regent
University. So
>> yeah.
>> Uh I just want to show you this. What is
Regions
University?
because that's where Erica Kirk went, I
think. Regents. Okay.
Uh,
maybe it's not.
>> London,
Private Christian University in Virginia
Beach. Yeah. Uh,
>> okay. That's not the one I was thinking
of. Anyway, she went to one that it
literally when you type it in, it says
is a Jesuit university. I was like,
"Wow."
>> Oh, yeah. No, no, this is this is from a
a hyper charismatic guy.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> Hired and exposed liar Urggon
>> Kanir. We're going to talk about him
more before Chuck Mistler placed Lehei
on his board of regions.
>> Oh, come on.
>> And again, all these are little issues
that we will get to in totality later in
the study. Tim Lehei said of Moon,
quote, "Your suffering will cleanse the
sins of America." End of quote. When he
was in prison for a time here and again,
we're going to get to that very soon.
And and this is all reference the the
stuff that we're talking about here. Um
there's a teaching that I did on this
previously that I just mentioned and
it's entitled Reverend Fwell, Reverend
Sunyong Moon and the Love of Money. And
this is from 2007,
May of 2000, May 20th, 2007. So it's
been quite a while now. There's a link
here. You can click on that. The audio
quality on my earlier teachings aren't
what it is today. I was still trying to
figure out more of the sound things and
and I went through a lot of sound
configurations. Not to say it's perfect
um today, but it was it's a lot better
than it was. But anyway, I'm just going
to give you the actual description of
this teaching. In this teaching, we will
we will be looking at the fruit of some
of the most prominent Christian figures
in America. This list will include Jerry
Fwell senior uh and junior uh Timothy
Lehei of the Left Behind series, Gary
Bower, Bill Brightite, Paul Crouch, Dr.
James Dobson, Billy Graham, Dr. D. James
Kennedy, Beverly Lehei, Ralph Reed, Pat
Robertson, James Robinson, Philip Sha
Schlafley, George Bush Senior and Jr.,
and Dr. Robert Schuler. Jesus said, "By
their fruits you shall know them." Which
is in reference to the fruit of a true
Christian as opposed to a
pseudo-Christian tear like the tears,
the wheat, and the tears in the Bible.
>> We will be looking at the undeniable
documented financial links of the people
listed above to the cult leader,
Reverend Sunyong Moon of the Unification
Church in Korea. Unbelievably,
good old Reverend Moon was actually
crowned Messiah and Savior of the Earth.
I'm not making this up. He was crowned
Messiah
>> and Savior of the Earth on March 23rd,
2004 at the Dirkson Senate office
building in Washington DC. Now, if you
don't believe that, click on the study
and you and you can click on the PDF and
I also give you the pictures here in the
study. Now, on the older studies, you'll
notice if you click on the PDF, it's
like a div share link. It'll take you to
another page and it almost looks blank.
There's not a lot. You have to scroll
down a little bit and you'll see a green
download button. Click the download
button and it'll walk you through that.
It's it's a little different um on my
older studies.
But this this devil was literally
crowned Messiah and savior on on on
planet Earth March 23rd, 2004
at the Durkson Senate office in
Washington DC where scores of quote
Christian leaders as well as several US
senators and representatives met for
this very blasphemous occasion.
>> Southern Baptist leaders were on hand as
well uh as were Trinity Broadcasting
Network uh President Paul Crouch. We're
going to talk a lot about good old Paul,
Reverend Jerry Fwell, Reverend Robert
Schuler, and again, I've done a whole
teaching on the title of Reverend, which
is totally unbiblical for a human to
take. It's only used one time in the
Bible where it's in description of God,
and it says holy and reverend is he.
>> If you want to hear that teaching, just
key in reverend in the search box at
contending fortruth.com
and you'll find it. It's only like 20
minutes long, I think. Uh also in
attendance were
uh Kenneth Copeland, Pat Boon and many
others. Moon claims this devil claims
Jesus failed on his mission to Earth.
But Moon has not failed.
This is one of the largest smoking guns
and flagrant moves ever made and
condoned by mainstream Christian figures
and politicians. This information is
based on highly referenced factual
evidence. We even give you the pictures
even in this study of the actual um
proclamation from that night from the
from this Dirkson Senate. I mean we we
show you the pictures of the guy getting
crowned. I mean they're putting this
crown on this devil.
>> Wow.
>> Face wearing I mean it's just it's
incomprehensible.
But this isn't something I've talked
about a lot in, you know, this has been
like 5 years almost since I did this
study, but it heavily relates to this
teaching we're doing today. And and when
you start to get a grasp, I like this
study because you really get a grasp of
the totality
of the the sheer vastness
of this apostasy
of the of the infiltration
of the so-called Christian
corporate church in America. It is
mindblowing
this information.
So, we're looking at a picture here and
it says, "This picture to the left is
from the Strategic Perspectives 2
conference when apostate Chuck Mistler
asked the apostate Tim Lehei to be on
the quote scholarly Coinia Institute
board of regions in 2007." Now, I did a
whole teaching on Chuck Mistler. This is
just confirming more of that. Okay? I
give you the links to the teachings here
or you can just key in Chuck or Mistler
in the keyword search box at contending
fortruuth.com. So, if you're like a big
Chuck Mistler fan and you're already
offended, well, I'm really sorry, but
the amount of evidence against the guy
is so overwhelming and it's just
building every day. Just like Tom Horn,
>> what he's doing. And Chuck Mistler and
Tom Horn are totally yolked up right
now. I mean, the next the next um thing
they're doing in Lakeland, Florida,
they're they're on the speaking schedule
together.
I am seeing such a gigantic push for
these apostate ministries to yoke up and
then point everybody to Rome,
>> to the Vatican, to the Pope.
I mean, it is so getting so flagrant and
so out of control. My job is becoming
increasingly easier by the week
>> regarding documenting this stuff because
it's it's so flagrant. It's so in your
face and it's so undeniable.
Wow, dude. So, when it came to Charlie
Kirk, you know, a lot of people had an
attachment to him. I fortunately didn't
know anything about him. So, I just I
didn't have any kind of emotional
attachment or bias when I was looking
into what happened to him and all this
stuff. Um, with Chuck Mistler, I
actually used to really be into that
guy. I knew that he was off on certain
things. I know he really believed in the
pre-tribulation rapture. I knew that
wasn't true. He teaches the Nephilim uh
idea, which a lot of people I know still
do believe that.
>> Um so I was able to overlook some of
that stuff, but wow, dude. See, this is
this is a situation where it's like
there's people out there that are saying
a lot of the right things so that you
will let your guard down, so that you
will fall for the deception that they're
giving you. the poison that they're
feeding you
>> and and they've been they've been paid
right they've been paid by and funded by
Sunyanm Moon and basically the
information that you don't know here is
uh and I'll give that now maybe that's
in the next video or so that it will
come but um Sunyan Moon uh basically
said that Christ failed on earth and he
is the one that is setting things right
on earth and his wife and he passed
away, right, recent a while ago. But his
wife is still alive and she was the Holy
Spirit and together are they they are
the true parents and what they do is
bring people together. It's a cult, man.
It's it's really crazy. They just bring
uh guys and girls together and they just
decide who's going to marry with who.
>> Mass mass Yeah, mass weddings are
happening at at their church. Um, what
do they call that? Arranged marriages.
Mass arranged marriages.
>> Yep.
>> Man,
that is crazy, dude.
>> And and he said that there was
all these like politicians and
evangelical leaders that were at this
thing where he's being crowned as
Messiah,
>> savior of the world.
>> Yep. All these guys were there. Yep. And
uh I think this guy that for for the guy
from contending I think contending for
the faith or whatever it is. This guy
also said in one of his videos that uh
surprise surprise Seyan Moon was a night
was a was a was a nice of Malta.
>> Not surprised. Wow.
>> Surprised? No, I'm not surprised. Of
course not.
>> So, uh all roads lead to Rome again,
right? So, it's it's unbelievable. But
he uh this guy also owned uh the
Washington Post. It's very conservative,
right?
>> It was Bush's favorite newspaper.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Now I know why. Because he funded Bush
and he owns the Washington Post. We, you
know,
>> the love of money is the root of all
evil. Money is not evil. It's the love
of money and the corruption that comes
with what you'll do. what kind of uh
compromises you'll make to get that
money.
Disgusting.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's bizarre. So now uh
so this is this very very interesting
because um so now you see uh in in this
video is older so you see some people
already passed away like Paul Crouch
passed away right but TBN was funded
>> fun was funded by by uh TBN and Paul K
is funded Billy Graham was funded by
>> uh Son Moon uh Jerry Fowl was funded by
and was built out when uh when when he
went almost bankrupt, he was bailed out
by or bought, you know, he gave money to
Jerry Fowl so that Liberty University
could be saved. Um
he also uh you know paid Tim Laay, his
wife of Tim Lehei was on the board of of
another conference thing. Um I mean and
now we're going to into the present.
though recent uh in the last time that
President Trump was was in office
uh some people went uh uh to some of the
Mooney's conferences
and um one of them uh is Mrs. Paula
White and she is
>> the faith leader uh back then and now
she's in the office of of faith whatever
she she's now in the White House right
as as a an official uh uh with an
official title
>> um and she was in one of our earlier
videos
>> like a faith advisor
>> was sitting down she was sitting down
with Lance Wallnau talking about the
seven mountain mandate Right.
>> Wow.
>> Very interesting. All these all these
connections, all these dots. Now, let's
go to video 19 and see what Paula White
did with the Mooneyies.
>> Wow.
>> And and all and remember
that lady that they talk about
supposed to be the Holy Spirit, right?
>> Okay. The wife of that Mooney guy.
>> Yeah. And the that's that's the one
that's still alive. the the guy is
passed away. So, but but let's roll this
video.
>> Okay.
So, we're going to look at um here I'll
play the video in the background. This
is um it give you an idea of the rally
of hope. This is 2020.
We're talking about major players. Okay,
this is this is the major players. Um
people like [music] the prime minister
um kingdom of Cambodia, president of
Sagal, Republic of Nigeria, former prime
minister of Canada. I'm Canadian. Don't
talk about my accent. It's a beauty.
Part of our culture. We say sorry a lot.
So in my videos, I say sorry a lot. It's
part of our c culture. It's a beauty.
And we also love the Tim Hortons. E. Oh,
the Tim Hortons here in Canada. E.
All right. So let's talk about it.
Steven Harper used to be our perime
minister. Paula White, Nuke Gre, and the
list goes on. It is truly remarkable um
who the Mooneyies are connected to.
We're talking about the people with all
the money, okay? And the government
leaders.
It's amazing. So, they had the global uh
virtual rally and I'm going to explain a
little bit about who I've done the other
four videos or three videos. You can get
a better understanding. We're going to
get into lots of videos today, okay?
Including to a video that she just
posted in January. So, high-profile
Christian, this is what I This is kind
of like why I'm doing this video because
this isn't something Paula White has
just done. She's been doing this for
years, years. I'm going to show you
right now. High-profile Christian work
with unification churches to bring only
begotten daughter of God of America.
Okay? Daughter of God to America.
>> So, who is Mother Moon? Who am I talking
about? Who are the Mooney? Well, if you
don't know who the mooneyies are, they
they call themselves the true parents or
considered to be God's chosen vessel to
bring peace to the world. Okay? And
succeed in the mission where Jesus
failed. Okay? They reject Jesus Christ,
okay? The true king of kings and the
lord of lords, mother moon is now the
new messiah here on earth. Yes, this is
the literal antichrist spirit. and Paula
White has signed on with her
>> for years. Go down to in two in in 2017
Manos Square Gardens Trump evangelical
adviser Paula White Kane spoke among
with other gospel singers. Okay. She's
been promoting the mother of peace or
the new messiah or the
antichrist spirit for years. the video
you're about to see, um, we're going to
listen to her speak a little bit about,
um, this is 2020, so 3 years later,
okay? And let's just listen to it.
There's some shocking things in this
video, and I'm going to we're going to
look at this the Bible a little bit as
well.
I am so honored to be with you and what
an encouragement to the body of Christ
and to you, Mother Moon, for your
tireless efforts and your work as you
have continued to bring faith leaders
from all over the world to work together
in peace and unification.
>> Okay, I'm going to let you listen that
one more time. Just when I first saw
this, I thought it was fake news. I
honestly I thought someone had done a
voice over. No one no one would ever I
would never have thought that and if the
the spiritual leader of Donald Trump is
somehow giving full credit and and
authorizing of Mother Moon. I thought
this was fake news. I couldn't believe
it is so satanic what she is doing. I I
honestly I had to check around. I
couldn't believe my eyes when I first
saw this. So let's listen to it one more
time and then we're going to get into
really going to get into some really
shocking stuff. So, let's listen one
more time and then I'll try not to
interrupt.
>> I am so honored to be with you and what
an encouragement to the body of Christ
and to you, Mother Moon, for your
tireless efforts and your work as you
have continued to bring faith leaders
from all over the world to work together
in peace and unification to bring
together people for the better cause. I
congratulate you. And while we see there
is much work still to be done, we look
at the great accomplishments that you
have set as an example for all of us to
follow. I'm reminded of the word of God.
The Bible tells,
>> okay, so she goes on, we're going to
look at the Bible verse. I got one, two,
three, three, four videos, three more
videos to show you. So she goes to 1
John 4:16. Now, if you if you're like
I'm a minister, okay? I did my Bible
college in Mexico. That's why I speak
Spanish, read my Bible every day. And
you know, if I were to think of one
Bible verse to talk to Paul, Miss Paula
White, or any of these
>> so-called uh faith leaders would be
first John 4.
>> Look, I just couldn't like, it's just
shocking to me. It's almost like it's a
absolute blasphemous mockery of
Christians. She's quoting out of 1 John
4. Look where she goes to it. But this
is 1 John 4.
>> Beloved, do not believe every spirit,
but test the spirits to see whether they
are from God. Okay.
>> For many false prophets. Now Paul White
claims to be a apostle prophet. Now
>> it it is shocking how many false
prophecies she's given. So every time
that she takes on the name the
reputation of God, okay, as a spokesman
for God and then speaks lies or false
prophecy, that's blaspheing of God,
okay? And gone out in the world. Verse
two. Now listen to this. This the Bible
tells us how to recognize who's who's
the antichrist. By this you know the
spirit of God. Every spirit that
confesses that Jesus Christ has come in
the flesh is from God. Not every spirit
that confesses mother moon has come in
the flesh to save the world. It's the
very definition of an antichrist spirit.
>> And every spirit that does not confess
Jesus is not from God. Okay? They're
confessing Mother Moon. Now, they do say
the name Jesus in her her mock church,
mockery church. Okay? But it's a
different Jesus. And Paul warned us
there's a different gospel, different
spirit, and a different Jesus. This
doesn't even remotely come close to the
Jesus of the Bible. Don't kid yourself.
This is a satanic satanic woman. This is
the spirit of the antichrist, which you
have heard was coming and is now in this
world already. Four little children. You
are from God. Praise the Lord. And have
overcome them. Praise the
[clears throat] Lord. For he who is in
greater he is in you is greater than he
is in the world.
>> Wow dude that is
I can tell this video is a little older
I think. So
>> it's 2020.
>> Yeah. Otherwise you would have thought
ah that's AI you know anybody can fake
it with AI. Whoa. Dude that's crazy. So
>> well there's there's websites there's
websites all over. You can look it up.
Oh yeah. There's a lot of information
out there even from the organization
itself and uh that's that's what there's
something that's scrubbed from the
internet. Um but she was also an
ambassador to the United States for the
official Moon organization.
>> Whoa, dude.
>> So, and I have a cop I have a I think I
have a a screenshot of it somewhere,
>> but I couldn't find it on time. But I
mean that's in insanity,
you know,
>> and that's that's supposed to be the the
the the
advisor of, you know, and and now the
the the spiritual leader of the of of
the White House.
>> Yeah. And and she said what she was
saying that that lady Mooney was doing
was bringing peace and unification. I'm
just thinking, you know, when they say
peace and safety, sudden destruction
will come upon them.
Um,
>> yeah, dude. That that's what people
don't realize when they think about the
mark of the beast. They think about this
system of false worship that's coming.
They they get the understanding, a false
understanding from these Left Behind
movies and stuff. Like, it's going to
look satanic. Like everybody's going to
be doing satanic rituals and sacrificing
to, you know, Satan and stuff, but it's
going to look like peace and safety and
unity and coexist. It's going to look
like everybody, we all worship God. It's
so beautiful, kumbaya. And that's why
it's going to deceive so many people
because they're going to be like, look,
the world's finally coming back to God.
like people are loving and accepting and
uh yeah, it's going to be very very very
deceptive.
>> Very deceptive. Now, you would think
like, okay, Paulo White, she went to the
movies, right? Um but uh there's way
more. I mean, uh, the, uh, I think, um,
um, I think it was, um,
Mike Pence has been speaking at the
Mooney.
>> Uh, and the other guy and Mike Pence
supposed to be Christian, right?
>> Uh, and then you also had, um, what is
the the uh, last uh, administration?
Um,
>> Biden.
>> Uh, he No, no, no. the the last time
that Trump was in office, the guy that
was leading the the
>> uh was he leading the Pentagon or No, it
was he was foreign foreign relations or
uh what's his name? there.
>> He was also a Christian and and also
like a pre-tribulation rapture rapture
guy
>> and but he's also a former CIA. Uh and
he he he literally said in an interview
uh that uh that uh you're supposed to
that that you're supposed to lie, right?
And that's all fine.
>> Wow, dude.
>> I'm like, okay. So, you're basically
you're saying that you're lying right
now, too.
>> Yeah.
>> That you could lie, right?
So, but anyway, so so the next video is
is uh is uh Mr. Trump himself and what
did he do?
>> Oh, let's see. Very interesting. Uh
>> oh.
>> I want to thank the Universal Peace
Federation and in particular Dr. Hawk
Jawan Moon, a tremendous person for her
incredible work on behalf of peace all
over the world. Her story of escaping
from North Korea at five years old at
the outset of the Korean War is an
amazing example of the power of faith in
Almighty God. I also want to thank her
late husband, Reverend Moon, for
founding the Washington Times, an
organization for which I have tremendous
respect and admiration.
>> I just can't even take this serious,
man. Like, what in the world?
It's like we're watching Star Trek or
something.
I know. I know. But this is all official
material.
>> Yeah.
Well, I mean, he's got this like spacey
looking cosmos behind him and he's
talking about, you know, the
confederation of peace and
>> Yeah.
>> Confederation.
[laughter]
>> So strange.
>> Did you say to pause it?
>> No. No. But but I I said uh I said the
Washington Post earlier and it's
Washington Times. But
>> Oh, okay. Either way. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Uh I'm trying to play it. There we go.
Oh, that was the end.
>> Oh, he's almost done. Oh, he was done.
>> Wow, dude.
>> So, he and it was not one time. I think
he did it twice. Uh I think after after
he also went again. So,
uh yeah, unbelievable.
>> Yeah, I've never seen this stuff. I want
to thank the Universal Peace Federation.
The Universal
>> sounds like Star Wars.
>> Yeah, [laughter] we're bringing peace to
the universe.
>> Obi Obi, what Kenobi, whatever you call
it.
>> It's not just peace for the world, it's
peace for the universe.
See, he's in space. See the See the
cosmos, bud.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> Yeah. That's
and and uh yeah so this
so the seven mountain mandate right is
kind of we linked that already in
earlier videos to uh to the new age I
think we did that right we we uh we went
through the new age uh from Alice Bailey
and the seven mountain mandate that was
very similar to the seven spheres that
the Christ would app reappear right the
reappearance of the
Uh so there's a lot of oultism in that
whole seven mountain, seven spheres idea
on its own. Now you have Michael Flynn
who is doing a prayer and it's supposed
to be Catholic prayer.
That's what he says.
But um he's uh basically uh um what is
it? She's um uh this is so Elizabeth Cla
Prophet is a newager. She was part of
the uh the society or this is the
theosophical society.
>> Oh
>> and uh basically linked to Alice Bailey
and and uh and what Blavzki and and all
all those people. So she's absolute
oultist. And here you see a side by side
uh prayer from her and from Michael
Flynn in a church. H interesting
>> mighty I am presence. I am here oh God
and I am the instrument of those
sevenfold rays and archangels.
>> We are your instrument of those
sevenfold rays
>> and all your archangels all of them.
>> And I will not retreat. I will take my
stand. I will not dare to speak. And I
will be the instrument of God's will.
Whatever it is,
>> we will not retreat.
>> We will not retreat.
>> We will stand our ground.
>> We We will not fear to speak.
>> We will not fear to speak.
>> We will be the instrument of your will.
>> Oh wow, dude.
>> Whatever it is.
>> What? [laughter]
>> Here I am,
>> dude. So help me God in the name of
Archangel Michael and his legions. I am
freeborn and I shall remain freeborn and
I shall not be enslaved by any foe
within or without.
>> In your name.
>> In the name of your legions.
>> We are freeborn.
>> Whoa.
>> And we shall remain freeborn.
>> We shall remain freeborn.
>> And we shall not be enslaved. should not
be
>> by any foe
>> by any foe.
>> Within or without,
>> or without.
>> So help me God.
>> God bless you. God bless America. Thank
you very much.
>> Holy moly,
dude. That was insane,
dude. It was like he was literally had a
script of a new age channeling, a
demonic channeling, and was reading it
and getting the whole audience to
>> chant back a a de a demon channelled
>> um yeah, a demonic channeling.
Whoa, dude. That was a good find.
>> Yeah, that was that was insane. Insane.
Uh when I when I saw that, that was
crazy. And here if you share my screen
for a second, Elizabeth cla prophet who
she is
mysticism, Christianity and eastern
religions, new age circles,
>> spiritual leader, founder of church
universal and triumphant uh a new age
religious organization.
Um and then um
anyway see I think there's something in
there that's was part or connected to
the this oh yeah theosophy the I am
activity Christian science
>> wow dude see and this is this is where
>> you will be deceived
>> if if you just fall for anybody body
using Christian terminology like Michael
and Archangel and God and all this
stuff, you're you're going to be
deceived big time
>> because she was doing that. She she's
this is a prime example. Here's someone
who is a newager, not a Christian,
>> and saying things that the church
>> was repeating because it sounded so
Christianlike.
>> I mean,
>> correct. That just shows you how
how how much the church has lost their
discernment
that you can I mean this seems like
almost like a a social experiment. Like
I wonder if I could get the whole church
to chant a demonic channeling. Let me
let me just read it and see what
happens.
>> Yeah.
>> Unfortunately,
>> how far the church has driven Yeah.
driven driven away. I mean, it's uh and
and and luckily some people uh found,
you know, found found found out about it
and and put it online.
>> Yeah. Uh but you know if you're there
and you just you you just
um basically pro proclaimed like a like
a
how do you call it like a
>> um
uh like a
>> like a spell
>> curse or whatever but it's like a spell.
Yeah. Like like uh you just put
something uh on you uh I don't know how
to say it. Like
>> you know [laughter]
what I mean? Right. So you're you're
you're speaking something out and yes
something might happen but it's occult
right speak you speak a curse over
yourself out and
>> and people think it's all Christianity
and all all fine because a guy claims to
be Christian
>> right yeah if that pastor got up there
and open up uh a book of Crowley and
started okay repeat this after me and
started saying all these things right
out of a Crowley book or a satanic Bible
Um, that's a dangerous thing. You're
confessing with your mouth freely.
You're surrendering. You're um, what's
the word? You're using your own free
will to chant these things.
>> Um,
I was just thinking there there will be
sadly there will be people who could see
this video right here and say, "Well,
you know, God can use anything. you
know, if God can use a donkey and you
know, I because I've heard people, you
know, I've done so many presentations
where I I show the blatant satanic
message of movie after movie after movie
that makes the villain look like God and
the hero is definitely the is a Satan
character. And they're like, you know
what? I I can see a a gospel in that,
though. And God can use anything. even
that satanic movie, he could use that uh
that movie to spread the truth. And it's
like, wow,
>> God could use a a demonic channelneled
writing to
>> for good.
>> It's like uh how how
it's a it's a Dutch saying. I don't know
if that's an American saying too, but uh
how you uh um
uh
hit straight with a crooked stick.
>> Oh, interesting. I never heard that one.
[laughter]
>> It's a It's a Dutch uh transl Dutch
thing translated literally in English,
but yeah,
>> uh you can't. Right. So, so basically uh
if if it's crooked, it's crooked. And if
it's false, it's false. And if it's
demonic, it's demonic. You cannot use
that for Christianity.
>> Yep.
That's why you got to be careful with uh
even these devotions and stuff like uh
Jesus Calling that book.
>> Yeah.
>> So I bet there's people in this chat
right now out of the out of the few
people that are in here, 66 people or
whatever. 77 people. Uh, I bet somebody
has it on their shelf because I did and
my wife did and
um, you know, many people I know have
had that book or have that book and are
unaware because man, I was reading it
every day as a personal devotion in the
morning and I was getting blessed by it.
I was saying, "Wow, today's devotion is
exactly what I was thinking about or
talking about yesterday." And um come to
find out [snorts] she was channeling
Jesus supposedly.
>> Yeah.
>> You know I met a guy I was doing
>> writing. It's automatic writing what you
did.
>> Yeah. I I was giving presentations at a
nursing home every week for a while and
there was this guy that he would he
talked about it every time. He's like
have you read Jesus calling? He said she
heard from Jesus personally like Jesus
told her right what to say. And I was
just like you're saying that like it's a
good thing but that's what is like a red
flag to me is like that she heard
directly from Jesus like what to write.
Um but yeah Dorene Virtue has a really
good video on exposing that
>> Jesus Calling book. Dorian Virture used
to be a psychic and was heavily involved
in the new age and now she she can break
it down, man. And that book is is a is a
twisted deception of a book.
>> Yep. Absolutely.
>> Somebody said, "Ah, yep. I used to read
the Jesus Calling books." Yep. I
>> think we all did.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, it's uh and and and and that's
that that's what the N is really about
as well. Like uh you you know you can
personally hear from God from God and
you can uh uh
it's like it's like um uh to to the
point that you go to the supermarket and
know should I
buy the green one or the red one or or
whatever, right? and and uh and oh uh
Jesus told me I had to go to this place
and then I could uh I could guarantee a
parking spot right and all kinds of
>> things like you know if God is blessing
you with something and that that's that
is uh providence right but at the end of
the day
>> uh you know
so many people are are talking about
yeah God spoke to me this God spoke to
me that but where is verifiable with
scripture because God is not going
against the scripture and and uh yeah
>> well it's this is
>> this is lining up with that guy whoops
wrong one I think um the dude that we
were talking about that got busted
recently Apostle David was his name
>> Joshua Media Ministries and it says
during a face-to-face visitation
appearance from the Lord in a dream in
his sleep Jesus instructed him saying,
"David, I'm giving you the keys to the
kingdom of heaven." He continued saying,
"Whatever you bind on earth," is that
what it says? There's something in the
way here. Yeah. Whatever you bind on
earth, I will personally back you up.
And whatever you loose on earth, I will
personally back you up. And so, this
whole ministry says that every person,
every Christian has should have a
face-toface encounter or visitation. But
you know what's funny? He's using he's
using a church discipline
passage and and uses that as as you know
uh what you bind on earth and uh and
bind in heaven that has nothing to do
with what he's talking about. It has to
do
>> with with uh like uh with with church
discipline if you read the complete
text.
>> Oh wow.
And then this is, you know, this is
people put their faith in these people
and then they get arrested for
misusing money and whatever else. There
was there was definitely some sexual
junk going on too.
Oh man.
Did you have uh other slides? I I don't
have anything.
>> Yeah. No, this this was all for now. Um
I mean there's so much more of course.
Uh, and well, this is not the last
episode.
>> Yeah, man. We're at the two and a half
hour mark like always, man. Cuz it's
always a deep dive. There's so many dots
to connect with all this and it it's
hard to get everybody up to par because
I mean, you've been doing this for years
looking at all this stuff and and and so
have I. And it's, you know, every time
we do a show like this, it's there's a
lot of kind of explaining and catching
people up and
really trying to show like this is a
deception. And I know it looks good.
It's supposed to. That's what deception
is. It It looks good on the outside. And
really, when all this stuff happens,
when church and state unite and they
start saying, "You know what? We
the world is so bad right now because
we've gotten far from God. And that's
why there's so many
floods and earthquakes and fires that
have been happening like crazy. Not
because of direct energy weapons or
chemtrails or harp, none of that stuff.
It's because we have fallen.
>> Yeah. It's because we've fallen from
God. And um this is why Hollywood is so
satanic and Diddy Files and Epstein
files and all this stuff. It it's like
everything is coming out right now
because it's order out of chaos. They
want chaos. AI, you can't tell what's
even real anymore to the point where
people are so
desperate that we're just like, we are
ready for a savior. And sure enough,
Satan is going to appear as Christ,
impersonating Christ, and will deceive
millions because he'll be doing lying
signs and wonders and miracles. And a
lot of the a lot of the Christian church
thinks that Satan can't do miracles.
That Satan can only do evil. He can only
produce fear and evil. But the Bible
literally says he's going to do lying
signs and wonders. He's going to bring
fire down from heaven. that there's
going to be uh devils working miracles
that bring the whole earth together, the
militaries of the world together to
fight against Christ. And so we're going
to see things that are going to blow our
minds and make us rethink everything.
And we're going to fall, many people are
going to fall for this ecumenical
movement because it's going to look so
loving and accepting.
And if you stand on thus sayeth the
Lord, if you're a person that says no, I
don't care what it looks like. I don't
care what my emotions are telling me, my
feelings are telling me, the goosebumps
are telling me. The word of God says
this is right. This is wrong. This is
the commandment. And as for me in my
house, we will serve the Lord. I choose
ye this day to serve the Lord. you're
going to be looked at as an extremist,
zealot, bigot,
um, hater, and you're you you don't
agree with peace and love and acceptance
and tolerance. Well, you need to be
removed from society because you are the
problem. You're the problem.
>> Yeah. And and even and even uh thinking
that they do God a favor.
>> Yes. Exactly. the people that put you
away will think we did the right thing.
You know, according to God, we got rid
of that person who's a Pharisee. You
know, they love People love to call you
a Pharisee when you quote scripture and
believe what the Bible says. It's crazy.
I mean, somebody uh commented on our
video about Halloween and said, "Yeah,
this is what a Pharisee would say. What?
That the Christians shouldn't partake in
a pagan satanic holiday.
>> No. And that's the thing, right? The
Pharisees were the ones that were
hypocritical
>> and and they added to scripture, right?
So So it has not has nothing to do with
they also also say like the letter
kills, right? They always talk about it,
but it has nothing to do with the letter
and the book, the Bible itself. It has
to do with the fact that they misuse it.
>> No.
and uh and uh misapply it and uh and add
to scripture. That's what they did,
>> right? He called them hypocrites. Um
>> yeah,
>> vipers and whitewashed tombs that are
full of dead men's bones. Wow, man.
>> Yeah. If Jesus is even calling these
people whitewashed tombs and snakes and
whatnot, then uh we we should be like
Christ.
>> Yeah. Amen.
Well, dude, this was very enlightening.
Especially, you saved the best for last.
That um that side byside prayer
with the the new age lady and the guy in
the church. That blew my mind. Um thank
you for sharing this stuff.
>> Also, I was also a Trump official in the
first microphone, right? Mike Flynn was
uh
>> he was a Trump official uh in his
cabinet. Yeah.
>> Wow, dude. Wow.
Yeah, man. This was crazy. Uh, thank you
for putting this together, man. This was
a lot of connecting the dots and thank
you for coming on and sharing it with
our audience. I know there's
>> absolutely
>> the all all the videos we do together
get a lot of views and and a lot of good
comments and stuff and so happy to have
you on and can't wait for the next time
we do it, brother.
>> Sounds good. Sounds good. So, thank you
for having me and uh looking forward to
the next one.
>> Awesome, man. Well, thank you guys so
much for being here. If this blew your
mind like it did mine, click a thumbs
up. It really helps get this video out
into the algorithm. It's a free and
simple way to support this ministry. If
you would like to support this ministry
financially or want to invite us to come
speak at your church or event or school,
then go to candidtruth.org. There's a
booking tab if you want to invite us. If
you would like to donate, you can do so
on Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We even
have Patreon if you'd like to do that.
We also have t-shirts, which when I say
this, I actually mean t-shirts, hoodies,
mugs, uh stickers, pillows, everything
that's on Teespring. I I'll warn you,
they are a little slow, but it will get
to you. If you want to order some of
these things, we get $5 or so from each
order, and it really helps to support
this ministry. just know that we are a
100% donorup supported ministry except
for when we go speak somewhere. And so
we depend on you guys and we cannot
thank you enough to those of you who are
giving. We see you. We love you. We
thank you. It's all because of you that
we can continue to keep this ministry
alive. And we just want to say thank you
and we love you. And we will see you
next time on Canid Truth.